hier on a perdu contre 1 perdu yam
nepomniachi c'était plus nian
nepomniachi c'était nian je sais pas
quoi bomber chez bongrain me fera croire
un peu quoi ouais ouais j'ai failli
casser une télé hier brat ok c'est juste
un cas sauf un même port n'est pas
menacé de casser un caisses déjà quelque
chose
ben non mais bon c'était quand même
n'importe quoi non non homologué
aujourd'hui faut y croire bon c'est
comme si c'était un match retour de
coupe d'europe perdue 3-0 2-0 l'aller la
droite fait un truc au retour on y voir
poule ils n'ont pas chialer l'an dernier
vous perdez 3 0 à barcelone
ils sont hilarantes fils de retour ils
sont revanchards ils se battent à fond
il veut remettre 4 0 de quoi tu es ça me
rappelle un match fera pas plaisir à
mathieu qu en est il est dans le chat
mais pas comme chez mon père est
d'origine italienne
thales sur l'italien je rappelle quand
j'étais gamin j'ai regardé un match avec
lui c'était bon à nancy ça va faire
plaisir à ma thuôt calmy rey ouais mais
pas c'est moi qui étais content j'ai
wiki française a gagné quand même et ma
vie de nos très mauvais match tu ne veux
rien compris non mais il m'a dit que
c'était un match de merde mais ils ont
déjà eu trois buts de base
non mais c'est un bon bandeau comme
zizou de jeu messi à des buts c'est que
c'est très mauvais match 1-0 ils
respectent pas j'avais déjà dit quoi 2 0
c'est déjà très grave on l'a droit 0
avait-il mis onze navarra sur le terrain
je ne sais pas quoi et oui ça va
rappeler des bons souvenirs mais là oui
non mais voilà tu te bats quoi c'est
faisable dans le sport tsonga une année
je fais agresser 2010 2011 2011 je pense
il était mené 2 sets 0 me le donnes
contre federer il a game design match
ouais sous sa gueule oui tu es français
n'ont pas de mental bonté sa finale de
grand chelem les noms mais en fait à un
moment en fait c'est parce que le mental
ton problème c'est que peut-être les
autres ont plus fort tsonga à un moment
s'il n'a pas gagné c'est juste qu'en
fait c'est pas simple de jeu nadal quoi
ou de jeu federer ou ou djoko ou pas
d'humeur et à 10h15
en fait ils sont très nombreux et très
fort et mes bons amis peut-on éviter dit
toi t'es nul moi je l'appelle björn borg
donc bon qu'il faut y croire aujourd'hui
faut se battre
faut pas aller à l'abattoir on y va on
lui roule dessus en plus au moins deux
finissants en plus yann avec les noirs
j'ai envie de te dire il va se partagent
tu penses à part en âge lors plus
apparent petrov assez les vraies
questions
non mais en fait ok j'ai pensé à la
petrov et d'ailleurs c'est ce que je
jouerai peut donner forcément mais en
fait c'est pas du tout son répertoire
il a joué une fois celui de choc au
grand prix de moscou a chassé m et je me
suis renseigné m héry mine de rien non
ça fait mal aux hommes et au jura pour
sa pelouse mais alors là tu te dis pas
du tout le temps fait la petrov il se
dit contrainte hoc bas à l'époque où
c'est à avancer les gens pensent et oui
avec les noirs tu dois jouer défensif
mais en fait pourquoi les russes contre
attaque et d'ailleurs alors ça c'est la
diva qui fait qu'ils expliquent déjà
vendu une vidéo que je t'ai pas encore
envoyé dehors je vais t'envoyer pour la
guerre alors il te dit que il croit les
russes ont mis à contre-attaqué c'est la
doctrine militaire qui était
complètement différente c'est napoléon
tu es venu à moscou et à défoncer la
gueule
bon du coup en fait oui des échecs c'est
comme la guerre contre napoléon bon la
défonce et donc forcément il faut
contre-attaqué en fait ils ont même
applaudi en route romaine il était pas
que cing vivien j'te jeu s'attaquent eux
4 a vécu prend 1,5 à moi je te le
reprend pas direct les deux maires déjà
rsa
je suis retourné à paris et moi je te
manges je te défonce moi je suis là
ouais moi j'suis là ouais je fais quoi
maintenant juin car il y en a quatre à
cavaillon m6
parce que lire c'est donc du coup en
fait il se fait il qu'ils ont copié en
réalité leur manière de faire la gaffe à
la manière dont ils ont gagné la
dernière grande guerre qui avait eu
avant qu'ils s'y mettent
mais ce serait quoi une ouverture de
suzhou je sais pas quoi là enfin ce
serait une ruine personne n'a intérêt à
faire la guerre faisons des ruines de
notre côté et puis je te propose nul
quoi c'est dans notre intérêt à tous vas
nous ce serait comme toi enfin comme
nous contrôlons tournoi très heureux de
tout les nuls faisant un petit nul de
salon si nous faisons tous nuls nous
finissons tous premiers ma vie bravo
papa pourquoi se battre on va se battre
bon
ce serait ça arrive sous je pense mais
c'est bon quand même les échecs de se
dire que c'est facile napoléon n'avait
pas été là s'assurer complètement
différemment
enfin nous a pas de petrov oui je suis
en défense je dois absolument défends tu
vas me barricader à fond non nous avons
un philidor aussi il pensait que vous
êtes 4,5 kf3 un peu faux quoi elle te
disais pourquoi a battu du bloc qui ont
un énorme fonds d'assistance déjà fille
dormait c'est papa pour faire le plus à
défendre votre allée parce que les pions
c'est la démocratie le peuple très
importante utilise des élites de merde
pour venir m'attaquer à tu bloques le
peuple le sirop des révolutions dans
l'actuel jardin du goût qu'elle pourrait
chuter de 4,5 pouces et quatre ça c'est
intéressant ou en miroir est sûrement
très fort je sacrifie un peu de peuples
mais pour autant prendre au peuple
adverse aussi menacé ça il vient de
prendre du peuple et moi je prends la
position n'est prête une autre le roi
nomme hk tu te fais ton de détroit
c'était fantastique c'est parti comme ça
tu mets un peu de louis xiv à versailles
ont des 3t l'atp pouces quoi c'est beau
de jouer comme ça c'est dans l'esprit
quoi s'est crashé en plus des nitrites
et super héros avec son rang des 3 il a
battu plein mais qui était très très
content comme ça va c'est très joli très
bien placé quoi mais c'est marrant mais
c'est quand même c'était beau comme dans
les échecs qui comparaît avec la vraie
vie à l'époque
enfin les livrer bataille pas avec la
vie comparer vraiment avec la guerre
[Musique]
ouais c'est marrant plus guy roussel je
savais que parler de vraie barry des
raisons qu'on lui ait dit ça j'y tiens
salut fabien gloire qui crée mg l
donnez-moi m merci à gilles haddrall ans
qui a agi au chili drôle ans qui après
un tweet frei merci tonton le pourquoi
et comment ça marche de son twitter le
chat fenêtre à jack fenêtres et attentif
des journaux le truc
c'est que je mette un petit tweet aussi
ce que j'ai partagé sur la tweet la
grotte qui a dépassé les 400 milles vu
du bon j'ai pas laïque et évidemment ça
fait chier tout le monde et j'espère que
tu ne partage pas que tu ne la main
banon je partage poche normal quoi
une attitude complètement seul oui tu
n'es pas toxique
c'est bien je suis fier de toi merci
non mais t'as regardé la vidéo quand
même jusqu'au bout tu en as tu as tu
profites d analyser tout ça quoi
j'ai déjà vu oui mais si j stark n'a pas
mis de live sur youtube va surtout pas
surtout pas j'ai quand même pas des fans
vu là bas non plus ouais je sais j'ai
pas la revoir
non ça suffit mais tu as tu déjà
téléchargé sur surtout rennes sont pour
la revoir tranquillement sur ton au rôle
exactement la regarderai plus classe du
lot de connexion un gars qui m'a écrit
une fois été très heureux que les vidéos
parce qu'il ya des vidéos de youtube
qu'on a fait qu'ils sont sur torrent du
pilat et télécharger dès 13h30 oui ce
serait bien qu'ils soient sur torrent
seulement si jamais un jour youtube
disparaît je les soirées que j'ai tous
les lots naik ce qui est dit une pointe
à un abonnement à des quatre un
abonnement un abonnement diamant ah oui
les diamants d'avoir un diamant on
attaque les leçons français dès ce soir
après pas mal de bons mecs qui jouent
des quatre ça ça pose du chef niveau vi
nations en sueur non face à d'autres qui
dopa je l'avais fait je vais attendre de
la slave dans le jeu ce que tu veux
oui mais ce qu'ils jouent vraiment là
cela je me suis pas messi mais joue pas
des quatre non plus par un moment tu
peux et sur un terrain neutre et pas de
prendre une prépa adverse quoi as tu as
le droit non mais c'est vous en fait si
les deux pensent que les glens falls est
réputé mais qui la joue quand même je ne
ferai pas oui mais je reste il a des
principes à bavois là juste pour te dire
navarra ça ça débite passe ailleurs nous
de partout ah c'est beau quand est-ce
que navarre navarra connaît-il encore
le truc avec h4 maxime bon là c'est pas
mal et merci je crois qu'il ya eu un
nouveau saab fab
merci at-il tel type qui savent au nike
prime merci tonton bien ces dames c'est
dingue quoique je sais pas tu auras
bouger tout un répertoire des faux noms
non obligés obligé mais bon h 4 c'est
justement en tire une folle parce que
t'as pas le temps de faire des cinq
bourges calais prend 3 5% se faire
défoncer ouais on l'avait vu dans la
partie a great choc
donc soit tu veux une sorte de benoni
soit je fais pas mon destin des deux
mois ça me dérangerait pas parce que je
capte pas non plus le coup de l'année
mais c'est intéressant c'est la roulette
saimone williams après ce qu'il a
analysé ça au point de trouver l'égalité
avec les noirs je sais qu'il ya égalité
avec les noirs pas tout le monde c'est
en fait tout le monde sauf à tout le
monde c'est bon mais est ce qu'il le
sait n'est pas bien chez 10 des gens sur
à mon avis aussi quand il pour trop
compliqué je n'ai jamais fin
c'est par loup solitaire pas à les loups
solitaires ils savent nous analysé
eux-mêmes solitairement quoi voilà il se
dit oui ma me tenais plus avec moi
où êtes vous il cherchait les loups quoi
pas vous mais je suis un sous sol j'ai
écouté une histoire incroyable hier dans
pop corn telle émission et de go bah ça
en fait ça rejoint les échecs ça a un
rapport direct au seuil est un mec il un
peu traverser le canada à pied quand il
est moins 40
bon il fait ça mais il raconte une
histoire assez marrante à un monde est
bon il marche il marche i marsh et ah
bon c'est la nuit elles et ils
commencent à entendre des bruits
bizarres ont ils un dijon nantes est
souvent seul ou quoi ouais en fait ils
voient des yeux qui le regarde mais
assez énervé quand yvon jeu dead space
et des loups des coyotes ont il a très
peur que ce soit des coyotes
il est très dangereux le coyote bon ben
là en fait bouillir où j'étais déjà
blessé donc bon il s'était blessé au dos
bon il est blessé il a froid il est
fatigué et qu'est-ce qui fait moi je
vois que tu réagis à cause des 55 mais
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient du coup
fantasme tata une meute de loups en face
de toi ou une meute de coyote est blessé
bon ben il a appris des trucs qui était
dans son
sac à dos sais pas qui les a levés il a
gueulé hyper fort il a couru dessus quoi
ouais bah du coup ils ont eu peur et ils
sont du bon ben alors on a l'air très
loin d'être au congo ils ont ils un
hiver très très fort ils sont partis
quoi pas on va t-il expliqué que les
animaux ils sont assez fainéant et ils
n'ont pas envie de se battre ont des
règles de l'art
ça les fait chier en fait ne veulent pas
d'odeur faire leur taille peuvent être
déçus que si tu montres que tu es blessé
tout bon ils vont juste que tu es pas
par plaisir
enfin justice à pas pourquoi ne pas
faire oui c'est navarra y est beaucoup
trop nul quoi bon je le bats mais lui
juste là tu te situes tu lèves des trucs
en l'air tu cours comme une merde tu
cries braff de très forts de ces genres
de grimper ou justin comme un fou
juteuse match nul quoi nous partons quoi
ailleurs c'est un peu ça la dans la
partie je te fais h4 dégage meilleure
attaque c'est la défense et latex et on
a besoin dans les villes comme quoi non
mais c'est marrant bon on met des portes
closes ce qui fait un bon petit jeu
assez vite ça ressemble à n'importe quoi
mais du gauche peut être on disait que
l'ordi donner plus 1,88 donc sur le
moment on va voir un pseudo y à t'il et
préparer quoi ces missions je sais pas
si ça existe déjà de la nouveauté parce
que là c'est bien d'être déjà très
chaude ou non parce que le 4 possibles
pour les blancs du coup devrait
peut-être que maxime gueule juste quoi
mais pop art de la part de la table
d'hôte qu'il est d'accord de formules
sont là surtout aïssaoui que là il faut
pas juste neutraliser les vous faut les
laitues et moi ne faut battre les loupes
1 min pour des jeux jean attend minaj a
juste eu ni bruit ni quoi toi un abruti
connaît déjà joué sa tvq qu à ce niveau
mais il convient de banque qui n'a quand
même pas de manquer il a juste confiance
à ses trucs et il répète c'est mais
c'est hallucinant pour moi de faire ça
ouais c'est foutu c'est que le mec s'est
préparée tu rejoues exactement la même
chose qui compte
l'ontario fait donc il ya six parties
dans la base mais bon la dernière un peu
intéressante c'est great food né peau en
août dernier amsterdam levitte of
rapidement le truc que vous avez fait g4
déjà maxime décrit tube non non non non
sur aussi si le feuilleton prend part à
l'échangé je t'annonce déjà j'ai quatre
dons qui suit le stream écrêtement ce
fut notre histoire avec la grob de la
forêt et se lance dedans quand il a joué
assez vite donc il connaît bon bah je
t'annonce victoire de maxime afab on
arrête manager cats ont l'esprit lot
bajard c'est déjà fini
bon c'est bien seulement mondialisation
mais heureux geodis gk profite pour pour
fêter les quatre cent mille vu comme
dégagé quatre nouveautés
enfin c'est pas étonnant il est aussi
personnel va jusque non mais en fait ce
serait vraiment beau que juste ça gagne
enfin coup mais je comprends c'est que
je choque pas mais je comprends pas les
jeunes adversaires qui ont des des armes
automatiques de partout bon tu peux dans
son bunker à un truc mais non tu sors
torse nu d'avoir mon bac et 28 youtube y
croire mais c'est bizarre pas ses
cachets de ne pas prendre un bouclier ou
un truc mais c'est tellement étrange
d'avoir joué bon après je vois ça veut
dire c'est gagné pour les blancs mais
c'est juste je sais pas mais tu as le
droit de faire russie cela juste et des
jouets bibelots par exemple droit
non mais enfin mais bon peut-être que
c'est pleutre comme approche de vouloir
dribble adversaire et c'est aussi la
preuve que t'es pas y perdre y en a peu
parlé mais mais là un fait divers c est
fou c'est vraiment lourd mais en fait je
peux pas comprendre les promeneurs 34 g
+ 3,8 non mais ça j'y crois pas vas-y
mais on n'est pas trop dedans ça me
paraît impossible mais vérifie on sait
jamais tu sais des foyers truc tellement
bizarre dans les échecs
bah écoutes je vais te dire ce que
raconte notre ami il a en tout cas là le
petit ordi duchess comme que je vient
d'allumer ils adorent ils adorent les
blancs non menu son voile il admis que
ses pattes la jarre après 20 à 4 4 c'est
même pas ce coup principe hull 6-1 voyez
donc je demande 60% pour les blancs quoi
ne sais pas mais il kiffe
non mais c'est très intéressant quoi tu
prends tu prends le centre ça vous
perdez le roi assez gros basque et je
suis fils un pion de merde
non mais je suis un peu abasourdi parce
qu'elle va le choix de néo pop art est
tellement stupide
c'est dans ce bar stupide mais deux
breaks sont vraiment enfin qu'elle est
désolée veut dire qu'ils sont vraiment
divine quoi que les imams et g5 l'autre
jour quoi faire ça c'est choquant en
fait de pas jouer en relation en
adéquation agression dans le match c'est
très étrange
non mais c'est ce que tu as et un gain
de 0 à l'aller tu viens à domicile est
en fait tu mets 5 attaquants défenseurs
et y en a mais je joue comme ça en tout
le temps donc je continue mais il y
avait hier un entraîneur comme ça qui
avait entraîné un peu chez piste et l'as
rome ou la lazio qui avait absolument
rien à faire du score en fait s'en fout
complètement il joue toujours à
meyrannes vrai c'est ça absolument rien
à [ __ ] ça ne m'intéresse pas et même y
avait un de ses défenseurs étaient
capitalisés que c'est la seule chose à
lui signer ils redescendent et
puisqu'ils menaient 2 1 à la 89e minute
non non
retourne devant l'autre le prix du lait
sont abattues voit du beau jeu mais je
ne sais pas c'est juste vous adapter à
la situation mais c'est pour quand même
c'est ben et le défenseur étant sur
total et your head au score je suis là
j'ai vu l'interview il comprenait pas
quoi fiscaux fait j'ai deux minutes à
jouer
baye modou lô tu joues vous remarqué
quoi bah non il dit oui mais si tu vas
les îles dont ils voulaient marquer en
contre et je t'emmerde je récupère que
l'on pouvait remarquer ça hallucinant
il y avait un bon livre sur le vrai que
les philosophies de jeu lui comme mai
[Musique]
mais en fait devancer une bonne
philosophie pour les jeunes pour
apprendre à jouer est toujours un bon
volant après quand tu as des enjeux de
compétition et c'est ce terrain c'est
une autre histoire je pense non mais
surtout moi ce qui me choque c'est même
pas ça en fait au delà de ça c'est ok le
mec te fais des 4 c'est une sûrement
déjà tu peux souffler de dire oui ce que
je suis là maintenant bidane classique
tâche avait raconté l'histoire des
contretemps maso ouais je peux l'art
raconté a fait jouer tout le temps le 4
jouer fut le cas tout le temps dont il
s'était préparé je joue des quatre ok il
me regarde il réfléchit un peu il me
fait des cinq passes qui joue tout le
temps des 5
oui je lui fais c4 et je sais que j'ai
tout le temps c'est ici je vais regarder
dans les yeux et en fait j'ai vu il a
bien enfin pour ça que les deux premiers
coups il a pris dix minutes faf
il suffit il comprend où je veux en
venir et machin avait fait aussi bien ou
toujours mears et qui veut vraiment des
cinq faut le dire je veux comme
hambleton et traite l'autre
ouais les gars pour la petite anecdote
je n'ai pas préparé plan parce que
j'étais sûr qu'il ferait passer en fait
ces trois qu'il y avait trois quarts et
je m'en fous ça il va pas ivan je sais
pas j'ai senti qu'ils rentraient pas là
tant dans leur fait j'avais préparé sous
les conseils de vlad heures j'ai préparé
le décès de l'année où il va sûrement
faire des princes et 4 plus logique de
jouer pions isolé pour te pour te battre
d'où j'ai préparé 3,3 pouces et kg
préparer un pur isolé on va y réfléchir
réfléchi je sais pas peut-être il s'est
même dit oui je vous avais des quatre
des cinq c4 il a peut-être pensé même il
a dû préparer des ces badges à l'état tu
je vais pas parler après la partie mais
peut-être qu'il avait eue tout la même
relation et eric van zyl a fait à prix
non enfin une certaine réflexion a fait
justice et je n'avais pas préparé du
tout est ok c'était une partie 20
personnes connaissaient rien brabus le
cadre un peu comme se fait 50 ans qu'ils
travaillent tout prix mais oui ils
étaient moins prêts que si je sors slave
du moment mais du coup tout ça pour dire
que chez payot cif un gros respect quand
même gros joueurs grosses réparations il
a bossé avec kasparov et tout et tout et
du coup il a quand même pris du temps
même contre un abruti fini que je suis
ce qui s'est dit moi je te comprendre où
il veut en venir le c'est d'éviter son
truc ouais mais là non classés à noter
des 4 5 et 6 ans ta gueule tempo c4 g60
joue comme contre
absolument c'est quand même bizarre bon
la menthue proche de 4,4 à main se voit
que je ne connais pas seulement à deux
fois j'ai vraiment pas de chance c'est
extraordinaire je commanderai jamais je
suis non mes copains comme je te dis moi
je suis enfin le choix déjà me paraît
très étrange ou quoi mais ce qui me
choque le plus c'est juste de rentrer
tempo ça ça me paraît hallucinant
théocratie ya même veulent c'est la même
empire des fois oui mais ça on rit on
est d'accord de grâce match c'est vrai
mais c'est pas parce que l'un fait mal
que l'autre doit s'inspirer quoi fâcher
ses motifs de faire pareil nommé hier en
fait j'étais surpris qu'il m'avait le
fons dans la jeune femme dès qu'ils
jouent pas la slave par exemple c'est
pas vraiment son histoire mais une
époque il a été mis à la joue et se
souvient gérard caudron 2013 ou pas il
en joue m bon du coup ils capables et
nespouls je pense pas qu'ils soient
grands joueurs de d4
enfin gérard n'a pas de sortir une idée
de fou sur un slap dans le bon je
t'annonce une égalisation je racontais
que vladan les marques grille tout âge 4
ouais ouais mais il a arrêté great
choqué mais pas parce que vlad l'a
convaincu il s'est auto convaincu il a
trouvé un du coup il c'est bon oui il a
mis quelques mois à trouver ce qui
prouve bien son vrai niveau quand il
travaille seul
maintenant il sait qu'à un moment donné
il pensait plus que ça à réfuter des
catéchistes ses cages et seaska fablab
imagine le niveau du mât quoi elle m'a
dit j'étais dans sa cuisine
je vis de façon enfin tu feras toujours
mal quand fatigue mais à quoi il pensait
que ça réfute vraiment oui je pense
non mais en fait c'est pas une histoire
de faim c'est géré c'est juste une idée
mais de là à penser que juste fait la
révolution complète
oui ça réfute non mais j'ai du mal à
comprendre même si tu veux juste juste
l'estonienne c'est quoi le problème a
réfuté jardin à l'italienne personne te
lances h45
c'est peut-être juste un coup jouable
mais je fais à des tarifs le h5 ou dh
s'excuse de qualité des trucs
bon ok je ne sais pas où transpose une
sorte de samy je sais pas tu t'es
sûrement souple c'est juste qu'il
trouvait pas d'égalité clair mais en
fait vladut il avait un autre argument
il est en fait qu'est ce qu'on s'en
fiche que tu es une égalité clair ou pas
si de toute façon tu es moins fort que
tout le monde dans cette position en
fait son point fort great choque c'est
les positions techniques la
compréhension profonde et tout ça face
et ça c'est pas du tout une position à
la grille tout qu on va de vadim est en
fait que tu sois mieux ou moins bien
avec les blancs contre m bella c'est pas
le sujet de cette façon de mec va te
défoncer à quoi qu'il en soit élevé
mieux calculer que toi donc en gros
c'est pas le sujet de savoir si tu es
mieux ou moins bien mais mais tu te
rappelles pendant live quand il est joué
h quatre grilles au contraire elle va
était complètement fou était déjà
désespérée de trois coups comment tuer
du site et non mais surtout que ça va un
double impact en plus j'ai déjà fait
mieux les cadors la veille en souffrent
un peu mais en plus en bon ça tu peux
fit le point de bonus à direct et ça
peut coûter très cher bon il se trouve
que finalement ghetto enfin il est déjà
qualifié mais ça a pu voir d'autres
répercussions d'ailleurs non mais là
c'est tellement une bonne nouvelle c'est
très chaud je pense déjà au moins 20 je
donnerais 70% de chance queen cette
partie voire même 75 des bocaux après
dix minutes de jeu
même pas c'est genre tu as perdu 3-0 à
l'aller après un quart d'heure de 0,3
0,6 vas-y je fais un tweet il y en a
marre nespouls en sueur face à l'élite à
temps non c'est très intéressant on sait
bien que maxime au moins une idée
fraîche mais c'est juste là pour le coup
enfin maxime très bien mais n'est pour
ultra naïf quoi mais c'est même plus
l'invité jeudi à l'ats
dire je mets un petit tweet parce que on
est heureux j'avais pas envie de tweet
avant parce que c'était pour soi la
défaite adam et là je le sens bien ma
main ce match non mais c'est pas encore
gagné mais au moins bon non mais là je
vivre c'est que j'étais complètement
malade hier soir à tous j'ai chopé
enrhumé toi cause de cette défaite n'est
pas commun mais il m'a vraiment mis dans
le mal vas-y je mets un tweet moi je
veux surtout pas demander aux gens de
retweeter alors ne re tweeté par un
serveur de magritte l'unss et surtout
surtout ne re tweeté pas ce tweet je
vais quand même à être un lien mais
vraiment pour que vous ne cliquez pas je
mets le lien du tweet mais voilà s'il
vous plaît on va on va tester une autre
on va la faire autrement fab 2
voilà surtout ne cliquez pas ne re
tweeté pas ne mettez pas de like
c'est vraiment important on alike pas on
ne clique pas on ne partage pas ouais
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment la base
pas bon avoir le réflexe tu as toi tu
marques tu as pas le réflexe des voix je
te vois tu l'as dit non mais tu veux
attends je vais voir je suis sûr tu vas
laïque et je suis sûr tu vas te faire
avoir
ouache un tout autre jeu des vols
instant je suis pas sur twitter
non ça va pas paniquer il ya des mecs
qui ont craqué à y en a qui aurait qui
re tweeté cric crac mais voilà là allez
nous c'est très autres u2 way 14 mai à
nankin mais là les mecs sérieux
enfin tu vois on part on parle d'un truc
on dit surtout on clique pas sur ton
retour tu pas sur ton like pas et là
vous tombez dans le panneau quaden
vingtaine de projets 4 tf3 jouer c'était
des coups normaux maintenant où aller
avec le flou jugé qu est comme ça pour
rigoler avec une infirmerie wailly près
l'annoncé vite il a fondé sa taille par
très loin par là où partirais-je 5
ouais pour couper la colle anfr rock
mais en fait ce qui est bien c'est que
les blonds un centre très stable tu vas
pas trop les attaques et il es tu vas
faire [ __ ] wadhams des deux grands
rock et puis et puis ton fois je 5 un
jour votre lettre un câlin j 3 ou 1 h 4
ou angers f 4 mois et alors que tout ses
impressions pourquoi êtes-vous aussi
content de l'ouverture pour est aussi
contente fab qui me dit que je suis
content du comment vous êtes aussi
contente n'ont été disent contents
qu'ils lisent pas contre un bond est
contente parce que ça se fasse pas mal
quoi fin on s'est pas fait égaliser la
gueule sur une variante ou l'autre à 6 t
il à une surprise et maxime et déjà je
pense mieux en fait objectivement dans
une position que je connais très bien où
avoir calculé attaquer donc c'est
jusqu'où la presse évidemment pas
gagnant encore mais ça pouvait
difficilement être mieux après dix
minutes de jeu
je pense qu'on pouvait pas être un essai
[Musique]
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
[Rires]
c'est beaucoup quoi
c'est pourquoi
j'ai craqué j'ai fait en retraite at
heart oui tu as à pau 6 fautes en cours
ou encore plus rapide qu'hier quand ça
doit vous êtes comme groupe nomi en fait
ouais je pense que ça peut dans une
heure peut-être on est tous au bercail
les mecs là non selon vous n'est pas
utile conscience imposition hyper
inventorié pas perdante mais bien sûr il
a compris que c'était fait avoir mais
enfin j'ai même pas les mots en fête
pour exprimer de venise ou non en fait
c'est oui mais chez passe était mené 0
et 15 40 au tennis tu viens de faire
deux double fautes
j'aime aller 15 afin de faire deux
double fautes sur cère une balle faute
et au deuxième tour n'a rien à [ __ ]
ressert une première c'est la deuxième
j'ai encore fait une double faute
hop c'est pas de chance non et c'est
vraiment gros tu donne le bâton pour se
faire battre juste mais vraiment taillé
sa fille qui la retraite sans faire
exprès ça va si t'as pas fait exprès ça
ça va mais mais normalement fallait
fallait par aux tweets là on a 29 28 52
j'aime ça vrai nom et non plus je vois
fab libye le premier à voir premier
retweet déjà tu vas être twitter it off
bon mon lit là il aime bien vous descend
pas de son maxi me connaît jusqu'ici
c'est sûr voilà je sais pas s'il
arrivait seul la f1 deux écueils steak
c'est pas mal et peu importe que juste
qu'il veut en fait ainsi retrouvés cinq
chefs ou trop sur ça va faire qui au
lieu 2 faire des tonnes caillage 3 tu
veux un plot dieu que je pense
après je suis peut être un peu bizarre
ce mois ci c'est une brune fait lui non
plus de rupture
je rêve 5 je fais ça donc elles vont
tulle organisé ces 5 tu vas prendre des
5,5 f4 ça va bien se passer
en échange von thadden un pion mais ça
me fait penser à l'esprit des avec un
peu comme les hollandaises tu fais g4 ou
quoi en fait où tu files un pion mais tu
prends le centre bon là c'est une
landaise et 7 mai
socrates puni que franchement c'est pas
sûr qu'ils analysent et jusque là parce
que penser que l'autre va répéter la
même ligne sachant que l'ordinateur de
davantage blanc c'est chaud non non non
mais il reste ambitieux mais du coup
juste tu sais que tu es bien et tu te
débrouilles présent l'échiquier je
n'arrive pas à m'en remettre en fait
pour le moment c'est oui parce que jouer
un truc douteux une fois il n'y a pas de
problème parce que l'autre a pas
forcément regarder et il ya l'effet de
surprise et c'est une fois que tu l'a
fait une fois c'est ce qu'on appelle un
one shot incroyable +5 nettoiement
exerçons bouge très bien changer son
attitude développe tuque lucho 5 plein
de choses faisons quand même attention
de ski hier derrière soi pas hyper bien
joué il ya mais il a dirigé par
difficulté vite
ouais mais j'apprends de 6 et 5 c'était
quand même un coût qui devait trouver un
vrai fou g5 tu peux te dire h six mois
le plus froid jeté à montgueux ghislain
et mais ouais ouais mais au moins déjà
bon petit rock et il va pas trop le
faire non mais je veux juste expliquer
pourquoi on peut ne pas jouer ou g5 si
on peut se demander ce que ce que les
noirs sont contents a fait cette
expansion achi g5 dorny pas contents
mais en fait bon je trouve qu'un fonds
g3 ma foi du pas si mal cette diagonale
j'aime bien je suis conduite en
développement déjà fait un grand roque
et avec les monstres à son nom mais je
suis 100% d'accord mais je veux dire par
là que t'es pas sûr à 100% que ce soit
intéressant d'avoir tu veux te pose la
question je peux dire oui ou si je fais
fujitsu et trois dames dès 2 h 6 et ça a
pas l'air mauvais non plus je sais pas
quel point rouge et 5 soit au meilleur
des thés ce que j'allais dire est ce que
fait ce que t'es pas content on aura
laissé les pions comme ça et faire foi
enfin séverine fait une vraie question
et merci non pardon femme de troupes et
et merci à rooney blonde et tony blondy
way qui a pris qui a pris de coty le
d'abonnement lui carrément même pas même
pas le prime il a pris l'abonnement
bah merci à tous la gorge merci merci
des les seuls les seuls qui pleuvent sur
la chaîne de chasse comme france
j'espère que tu as comme du coup ils
vont dire
on fait plus de live ouais je peux
lâcher d'ailleurs une info tu as comme
la hérie ce nom parce qu'ils ont dit ils
m'ont dit que la chaîne francophone
sétaient celle qui marchait le mieux sur
twitch de toutes les chaînes
internationales
je dis ça je dis rien c'est un bonus de
fin d'année en fait je me suis rangé
bien profond non mais j'espère qu'on
puisse avoir plus de live et plus plus
de budget en général avec the vont
continuer à faire dés l'âge et donc du
coup merci à vous de saab et merci à
vous de nous suivre et les follow tout
ça parce que c'est quand même pas facile
d'être devant les russes et les les
espagnols à ce niveau là quoi passer une
même dur sur les sites des chèques en
général les espagnols et les russes sont
devant le francophone des jeux un peu
drôle tu vas sur youtube et où les plus
gros chêne sonar us ou aux anglaises
magny cours en guillemets anglaise on
compte même pas mais de quoi anglais eux
non plus compte pas et merci à mercy a
father choc pour pour le seul merci
tonton et si vous faut la chaîne faut
aussi aller faut la chaîne bitstream
vous trouver le lien juste en dessous
non mes joueurs c'est enfin voila vous
fait plaisir les mecs parce que c'est
assez cool quoi est-ce qu'on a une
chaîne perso battue peut la trouver
juste en dessous la chaîne perd sont en
fait pas le lien bitstream directement
fait 1 cf
tu vas tu tu cliques tuque et il y aura
plus de live en janvier-février de
celui-là pour le bougnat le tweet chez
il ya youtube mais sur mes études ont
beaucoup beaucoup de 2 depuis de
nombreuses années ouais mais youtube
france ils doivent tous connaître non
mais je sais pas tony bloom milla
populaire de connaître forcément petit
les nouveaux et ben voila vous lâche
l'info du lieu qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver les dates des candidats ce sera
du 17 mars au 5 avril je crois bagdad en
france le 15 mai je construis 15 6
arrivées des joueurs conférence de
presse tirage au sort plein de trucs le
15 arrivée du joueur le cese tirage au
sort le 17 mai reuters quand même du
15au 5 firebird qui donnent un écho le
cavalier d'or 2010
du choix d'ouverture le plus pertinent
12le pour cette panne klein cahier de
plomb du coup alors je pense à carré
d'art file à raison les échecs on fait
tout à l'envers
oui et merci à 20,23 pour pour le tweet
du problème merci tonton merci riou donc
nîmes sol cuisine et pau il fait moins
le malin au niveau du temps que
d'habitude
bah oui j'ai voulu faire le malin les
premiers coups du coup est ce que font
ou 3 était joué non c'est moi qui c'est
moi qui divague
excusez-moi l'élite normalement 9h à
wise a fait un nul sous bush ou une
soupe du partage ta anamorphose ci qui
nous écrit cne peau il s'est dit là je
vais te jouer une ouverture il ya que
trois personnes au monde qui savourait
cette ligne et j'en fais partie
donc voilà au moins de suite bien sûr
que je vais la jouer cavalier de où je
savais que dos au mur si tu devais faire
quelque peu neutre
c'est logique 1 et je pense fouet trois
dames des deux ce serait mon choix perso
vraiment je pense vraiment pointu âge en
blitz je ferai peut-être fou g5 parce
que j'étais en ville j'aime bien créer
des menaces ça me fait plaisir cela se
sent bien sur tu me connais je m'adresse
aux cinq je suis très heureux comme
l'ubs venait à se gagne classement
paraît justement on sait pas faim et du
jeu un truc il a des sujets sains et ang
lee durée sur en fait flouer 3 et maxime
linverse en vue du riz sur mon fai fouet
trois c'est un mauvais coup en longue
j'ai le temps de voir quoi bon du coup
tu m'as 68 voilà tu forces at il jugé
cinq ans bah je pense parce que t'as pas
de bonnes cases jordan 17 pour t'enlever
tu perds ton tué près de 5
si tu vas ailleurs je rendais cistude
pour une fourchette
bon ben arfa et c'est normal enfin je
dis ok mais tu peux faire [ __ ] ouamane
en russie ouais c'est pas si grave qu'il
gagne un tempo quand tu feras d'amener
de wave ou alors ils te laissent tout
rendant la justice te rend l'option les
hôpitaux mais bon je veux juste te dire
que x h4 c'est pas automatique en fait
comme décision je suis d'accord avec toi
je pense vous h4 plus fort mais c'est un
choix automatique choix h cup c'est
comme les antibiotiques c'est bien que
tu achètes un faux et merci à ce quoi
l'eau pour pour le tout merci tonton tu
fais rêver
il vous fait rêver soit le 3 square le 3
qui à la chaîne switch prime est
peut-être une peut-être une pause une
pause au smecta là pour pour les peaux
on est un peu une info du chat
apparemment il serait allé il serait
allé prendre du smecta à la suite cette
ouverture fouet trois joué par maxime et
s'est soldée par un dépôt il joue vite
indique encore apparemment après la
prise du smecta après moins de fouet aux
ils seraient ils seraient en train ils
seraient revenus
est-ce que dépôt est favori face au
vainqueur de wailly navarra ça dépend
qui gagne avec versons et merci à
howling magic qui donne le vrai merci
tonton il serait pas vrai qu'on avoir de
laquelle des deux bons plus que le 20
mai mais malgré tout c'est génial
l'appel nepomniachi coup dans l'alcool
ce chat est très élitiste ça a été
traitée ici on refait le test du on va
essayer de faire piéger on vous remet le
lien pour partager le twitter afin de ne
pas porter je n'ai pas partagées non
mais justement on vous fait croire enfin
on vous met le lien pour pour faire le
test est bien sûr que vous ne partagez
pas vous a l'air d'être très chaud
aujourd'hui donc on sent que vous êtes
en capacité de ne pas partager surtout
ne pas dire
et ce tweet non non ne diffusait pas
cela il ne diffusait pas les échecs
restons en petit comité fab et voilà ce
que les infos qu'on peut lâcher les mecs
qui vont écouter pourront leur faire
dans leur parti et ceux qui n'aiment pas
le savent pas c'est ça ne leur donne un
avantage et un mec qui m'avait dit ça
par rapport aux pions isolé sur la terre
mais je vais plus lever plus en parler
du d un mec qui m'a dit je le recommande
pas dans mon club pour que les mecs
sache pas jouer le pion isolé moi je sai
logique et merci à gros gros gros bg qui
lâche le prime et voilà tonton mais
voilà les prime qui lâcha léon on à 76 a
bola on monte à 120 sans abo sur la
chaîne chaise comme un jeu où on met à
léon mais daniel rey une chance sur
aujourd'hui en a marre daniel reyne
chance sueur qu'est ce que tu veux votre
sens à vos appareils c'est pas ma chaîne
a changé de se dire qu'on va demander un
budget à rennes y aura sans abo voilà
moi mais gérard elle se paye buralistes
mais non les pèlerins live spécial soit
enfin je m'en fous on va être prêt à
aller à 100 ha bon on demande du fric à
rennes j'étais gamin qui ne comprend
rien aux tweets bah rien des tweets sur
twitter
moi je vois t'as pas twitter déjà bon tu
peux rien et si t'as twitter c'est juste
dans 38 essais
partager auprès des gens qui peuvent
avoir accès à ce que tu dis le tweet de
kevin donc il a juste dit aujourd'hui il
ya la demi finale n'est peau contre une
v elle allait au jour par france à tout
ça mais c'est un maxi mais il donne
l'adresse du lien sur du live là pour
que les gens qui savaient pas puissent
venir et que y ait encore plus de monde
voilà c'est juste solide ouais et donc
en fait c'est un piège savent que là
comme ça en fait tu permettrait de voir
la de profit la risée les échecs et
c'est donc être l'idée c'est de surtout
pas partagé pour il nous dit qu'il a pas
twitter est il à l'abri de tout dérapage
oui merci ascal web qui a pris un
abonnement de niveaux pour une durée
d'un mois merci tonton à l'accueil jeu
de joué par maxime lecavalier qui va
partir en f4 fab n'est pas rien et puis
c'est quoi ce qui a valu à 5 c'est une
option pour pas justement ne soit pas
plus dégagé plus voir ta gueule quoi qui
ont franchi ce week-end un f4 quand même
super fan des deux si on se développe à
troquer tu n'es pas dans l'esprit et
humains les noirs sont pas devant
l'esprit en ce sens le cavalier rouge
adam est bon pour enfin grax une qualité
noir
je suis là c'est indéniable côté n'était
pas armé c'est choquant mais j'ai filé
une qualité en pions joue quoi tu
menaces en plus un truc sur quels points
6 faut s 4 et kyle eastwood
non mais c'est pas mais juste pour dire
leur didonne que 0,60 pour les noirs là
après qu'on ait fait n'importe quoi avec
les blancs donc c'est quand même très
bon signe kevin a très bien remis de sa
dépression dire une petite soeur
fouilles mam et georges été commandés
privé avant mais je vois à l'époque tu
fais n'importe quoi
forcément je suis heureux quoi
alors juge qui en huit ans une belle
énergie les planètes sont alignées ouais
on envoie toutes les meilleures vagues
qu'on a nva les pions et on espère quoi
ses forces et pas en étant désespérée en
faisant la gueule qui va gagner on lui
envoie tout le tout le plus positif
qu'ont et voilà il faut du flux positifs
faut y croire c'est que comme le france
l'ukraine
tall mamadou sakho qui assure gilles
quoi bon voilà niveau s'il a surgi à
hyannis port à wil a pas de façon il
peut faire comme thierry henry contre
l'irlande quoi as tu as touché la pièce
savez quand le but de la main quand même
les peaux a touché son roi ici le contre
hockey larbitre gelé vue il a joué tous
ses quatre années déjà que leur dites
merde c'est pas si comprendre simplement
interdit de calais f4 prendre un thème
bowser ton foutu va changer de fai fin
alors presque autant bijoux etc et f4
tout de suite ou plus tard aussi juste
bouger ta dernière rocks qui payons donc
bien envie de faire des champs de foot
complètement fou et très longtemps mais
j'avance petit chanter quand même des
pauses si tu savais mag robe ou je te la
mets j'étais très très chaude qu'il va
faire j'étais chaud j'ai failli me lâche
et là tu vois je me suis retenu j'ai
senti que c'était en train de partir
fable la 9e session sortir un vrai jeu
je sens je sens que ça va changer sans
les mecs j'ai presque envie de mettre
une limite moins de dix-huit là pour
pour ce stream parce que je sens que ça
va partir là bas me fait tellement
tellement n'importe quoi à l'epo non non
mais ça va pas c'est son choix qui
horrible après il va pas de la partie
comme ça g la gagne
mais le choix est un peu critique à fond
ces problèmes des gens critiquent à fond
de base quoi qu'il en soit wen en
peut-être fois je crois aussi on est
dans le chatt 6 et paas pas bête rock et
baroque
d'ailleurs c'est pas et b3 il part en
assises dam des deux tu fais grand roque
diagonale vie des gens fin non non non
tu veux tu peux contre tous les goûts
sont m je vois que leur 10ème beaucoup
moins mais moi même visuellement ça
j'adore enfin j'ai gamin fois je crois
qu'il te découpe là je te découpe la fac
qu'est ce que tu fais face c'est quoi
ton projet ça c'est encore des mecs qui
n'ont pas écouté macron avec avec toi g
et géant au bout d'un moment le mec tu
allais poutine poutine à fond tu vois ce
que je veux dire leur traverse la rue
trouva va trouver du travail parce que
j'ai envie de te dire non non je le sens
pas l'année prochaine ça c'est super
pour l'honneur lors l'ordi change d'avis
ça a duré 25
cette histoire m'a tuer me dis ouais
quand je prend un coup de vieux fin que
lui aussi c'est pas comme ça qu'on a
pris josé chacun notre et mais bon le
truc c'est que c'est bien aussi que je
puisse critiquer que parce que c'est des
mecs qui ont 300 pour lui puisque -
quasiment et crédit
dick c'est sûrement la bonne approche
mais je peux pas trop choquer mais ni
pour bus qui joue je n'ai pas faim il a
pris que 13 minutes alors qu'il surpris
se prend une prépa je sais pas tu as le
temps à fléchir si tu me le font ces
huit ont 17 ans de 6 soit neuf ou devant
h5 escouade fait pousser 4 tu fais g5 ce
que tu fais que ça vaille est tellement
de coups candidats à chaque coup et
sheva le mec hyper confiant quoi dans
son bain donc j'ai combien des lola je
sais pas 22 2526 ils n'ont pas
complètement 300 points mais pas loin
juste le frère d'un des deux grands rock
et du gard
4 un hasard vous fâche 80 heures après
peut-être l'ordi te fais cagliari 4 et
machin parce qu'il veut peut-être blanc
séduit au sein que si quelqu'un avait
quatre maintenant que tu as touché
l'option hd noir tu peux avoir ce genre
de trucs compliqués non seulement il
peut connaître
c'est sûr qu'ils le all in the dark
quoi encore une fois je me suis fait
avoir par les prépas
brocade cisco 4,5 et 6 je peux
comprendre c'est être signés parce que
concrètement ces totalisé de l'ordi un
jeu mais mes juges jouer coûte dame
grand roque quand même juste ultra
logique coin et je veux dire c'est quand
même grâce à vlad que c'est un peut
débloquer tout le monde pour que lâcher
les joueurs de l'élite 1 avant on avait
un peu plus peur on est un peu plus
prêtres mais une fois que dada clash et
déjà tout le monde maintenant tu dis que
c'est normal ça me paraît être un lieu
commun ben oui né peut qu'attendre de
teint joueur de ce niveau afin
d'attendre mieux en ouverture à la
rigueur mais moi je m'attendais vraiment
pas à ça et on veut juste que je veux
dire c'est que sur e4 je m'attendais à
ce qu'il rende pas un hasard mais quand
je vois ça en fait j'utilise très foncé
à fond dedans c'est évident il va pas
chercher afin de petrov je ne sais quoi
vous avez vous l'a dit aurait dit sur le
live très clairement je ne m'attendais
pas à ce qu'il soit russie nul quand
même bon je m'attendais à quelque chose
de très mauvais de sa part mais pas
autant quand même il a encore repoussé
ses limites extraordinaire morewood faut
qu'à la partie des gens est très heureux
on chantait tout s'est pas fait bah
écoute heureusement qu'on est heureux
heureusement tu 6 navarre est un 4 4 2
chez nice aurait cessé de l'ugema quoi
le la poupée de chiffon c'est vraiment
le valère germain des échecs madoff
oui mais dreams alors il pas mal en fait
il y joue à l'om j'ai causés mais le
championnat c'est des bonnes rentrées
mais bon c'est thomas ici puis c'est
tout mais non on va plus pour le coup
une avarie vraiment très gentils à
tandis qu'on me croie et super faible
par rapport aux tiens j'ai un peu levé
mon micro ou baisser le tiens d'ailleurs
battu fais ce que tu veux
oui on entend beaucoup trop fab besson
là
non non il y avait vraiment un truc
pareil quand je parlais fort et que je
lis un peu mais là comme j'ai un peu un
peu baissé le le volume donc mais
coûtera recommence à sa compagne de
saint brieuc aux objets pas de fauteuil
à le fauteuil fauteuil gamer en plus un
tu as un fauteuil et tu te sens pro de
roquettes league
on se sent gamer a travaillé à wollerau
kettling d'ailleurs d'aucune en argent
il faut que je passe un peu avec la
manette
non non c'est chaud c'est chaud ses
cheveux bleus font faire des reprises ou
non mais on a joué avec le mec qui était
hyper fort là il m'a dit que les 4000
heures de jeu tu vois ta j'en suis loin
encore mais m'a dit il était tout de
suite très bon moi j'ai été tout de
suite très nul je pense que même à 4000
heures de jeu tu vois mais cette demande
de des styles de jeux vidéo de voitures
non à ça un des jeux les plus exigeants
je pense en terme de ce qu'il en général
de jeu de voiture et de jeux de foot à
la fois voiture j'étais très très nul
jeu de foot je mets ces c'est très
spécial comme j'ai en fait c'est
vraiment très difficile
c est toi y'a pas de conduite de pain si
enfin ça aucun rapport ni avec la
voiture en avec le foot en fait c'est
fou mais c'est dur vasella font voler
sur le toit récupérer le ballon en l'air
enfin faire dépassera c'est très
compliqué donc je prends la fifa lors
fait moi j'étais plutôt ps que fifa est
en fête
ok mon préféré vous ont déjà c'est un
truc de vieux c'était de ps6 donc 2006
bon je prenais un peu synthé bon c'était
pas une équipe de fous tu vas tu te bats
avec le choeur dont il donne tout utac
la télé sinon la france je vais bien 10
ou qu'ils vont encore des petites
roulettes quoi envie de vendre le
dragster c'était bien quoi barcelone
déjà hyper forme et avait des petites
équipes sympa
roma où je prends l'équipe espagnole
débile mais parce qu'il y avait qui je
pas mal sûr du plan reprend des clubs
anglais que c'était bon on va toucher 6
à une équipe de fous etc robben sur
l'ale drogba s'était asséchée niko ça
envoyait bref j'ai tester fifa 20 la
avant-hier a franchement il est nul non
mais vraiment en fait fin le 19 déjà été
moyen mais là le vin je comprends
pourquoi tous les gens sont énervés et
vraiment nullissime enfin vraiment faim
c'est hallucinant seul problème c'est
une époque là bas alors c'est toi et moi
c'est moi qui comprend pas les
mécaniques de jeu ou quoi mais jamais
des joueurs qui font des des appels les
appels de balle ils sont mal faits la
défense est mal fait tout est mal fait
et fifa 10 9 t d a vraiment bof mais là
le vin je crois qu'ils ont encore faim
je le trouve vraiment nul
mais genre vraiment je suis peut pas
expliquer
c'est même la vie de saint gilles va
tout va pas en fait n'est joué mais lui
donne au top
non mais laissez moi j'étais toujours
plus tôt ps du coup parce que j'avais
bien inspirés de saucisses et comme dit
mathieu rio ferdinand extraordinaire
manchester avait une belle équipe
louis saha était très très fort théroux
net
[Musique]
cette adresse et s2 est beau match et
une belle époque
guissé fiche à 17 et fait correct mais
je sais pas a déjà en attaque
non mais c'est là c'est vraiment
horrible le gameplay est vraiment mou je
sais pas tu as envie de plus d'appels de
balle de match en transformant un jeu de
gens vont en fait tu as beaucoup de mal
à marquer avec des centres aussi c'est
complètement débile
en fait votre vote c'est très difficile
de marquer de la tête quand à déborder
enfin non mais c'est vraiment mal fait
enfin ça ressemble pas au foot quoi faut
vraiment tout jouer dans l'axé effacé
des bilans fait les plus crues nous dire
398 à calais a été génial ça que j'avais
bien aimé moi le l'édition spéciale vous
avez fait pour la coupe du monde 98
ouais c'est bien cette édition
non non c'est c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment pas terrible je suis à cette
année mais je sais pas en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya de moins d'1 les
gens sont très heureux des jeux mais en
fait pas si c'est moi qui ai ville ou
quoi mais j'ai l'impression que les jeux
sont de plus en plus nul non mais c'est
peut-être nous qui vieillit sont à
prévoir notamment qui te font de plus en
plus un beau graphisme oui mais après je
ne sais pas si l'intérêt du jeu ce que
ça vaut la jouabilité plein de choses on
lit que justement du cuivre ou même
temps c'est pas faux gratuit face à ces
cas est le char louis dit non mais
carrément kiev et le chien loup si tu
joues pas au bon jeu ouais mais c'est
quoi les bons jeux j'ai envie de te dire
quels sont les bons jeux les calculs ne
sont pas bons kevin bon peu tu a fléchi
pour le coup pong c'est qui aura été
curé paraît que c'est pas mal
jean mary troll il y en a marre de
witcher 3 il paraît que c'est pas mal
mais en fait c'est tu sais peut-être que
ce que je kiffe avancer un peu comme les
soviétiques il ya un truc que j'ai
compris chez les soviétiques et quelque
chose qu'ils aimaient bien alors en fait
quand tu arrives en russie un truc qui
est bizarre c'est qu'ils te si tous des
passages de films tahiti ils ont les
mêmes rêves et je suis dit c'est pas
possible
comment les mecs se référant fins
rituelles s'étaient attablés là les mecs
se s'envoient des répliques de films
dans la gueule comme ça ils auront tous
le genre non sur le dîner de cons un peu
peut-être par exemple ouais mais il ya
beaucoup plus de films et ils les
connaissent vraiment où c'est vraiment
les répliques par coeur
et là tu te dis pourquoi voilà voilà
et en fait ce qu'ils avaient très peu de
films est avec eux les films soviétiques
y avait quatre cinq films vraiment connu
par an qui sortait des grosses
productions soviétique et les mecs on va
comme il est passé à la télé dix fois
par an après fin est en fait ils ont
tous vu les mêmes films 40 fois et donc
du coup ils sont très heureux des
anciens films mais c'est pas qu'ils
aiment les fins il aime les films déjà
parce qu'ils les aiment ils ont eu
beaucoup de froid qui même s'ils sont
très heureux de pouvoir tu vas faire du
ping pong film
quand bien même des scènes mythiques que
je connais où tu as un mec je crois que
c'est kafka plessis ça c'est dans le
kidnapping caucase ouais ou à la
kidnapper cocasse j'ai pas contredire çà
et là en fait t'as un mec bon il fait
semblant de faire une simultanée aux
échecs pendant que tu le vois bouger les
pièces puisque vont les échecs en ligne
on se dit il est important est en fait
la blague c'est qu'à la fin
en fait ils jouent aux dominos fait une
simultanée de dominos et donc du coup
quand tu as josé chaque et toutes à des
mecs qui savent pas jouer qui vont on
fait quoi on va se faire une petite
partie de dominos
ça c'est un genre à un jeu de mots par
rapport au film référencé où le mec fait
une simultanée de dominos d'achat c'est
beau par nature tu te référence et du
coup c'est parce qu'il y avait moins de
voilà en fait comme il y avait moins de
films les gens voyaient les mêmes films
mais il était très heureux de sceller
cité peut-être qu'avant tu vas toi t'as
jouissif à 80,18 moi aussi tu parles de
chez à 90 qu'il est tout le monde avec
lui à 98 tu vois tu veux dire un genre
de toi on a nos références ouais et
peut-être que c'est ça en fait qu'ils
aient plaisir mais c'est un peu comme
les échecs tout le monde joue aux échecs
paravent du coup ça a créé une vraie
culture populaire voilà ce que dit arrco
donc on joue au même jeu mais comme
c'est pour ça que les échecs reste
populaire tout le monde josé chaque fois
tu vas dans la rue montcalm 190
personnes qui osent échec qui le dira
non d'hommes ce2 est-ce que les tontons
flingueurs sont déjà passées en russie
alors faut savoir que les les
soviétiques il y avait deux types de
films qui regarde et on sait les films
soviétiques et les films français
ils ont un grand respect pour la france
pour copains mais pourquoi est elle
toujours pas papa tchimou est niet
collection très gros en quoi ils
finissent avec leur chanson merci
beaucoup de partout merci beaucoup il se
marre d'être vendeur remercie beaucoup
un axe qui le donne c'est que c'est pas
mal
il veut faire un grand roque en plus
peut-être avant tout faire des
découvertes chez pas dans des variantes
et 6 et noir sont ramenés à juin comme x
6 au pire tu fais de cagliari 4 à ce
moment là pour gagner un temple ouais
donc j'aime bien un homme charmant qui
avait déjà joué quand même grand roque
et là je sais pas ce que vont faire les
mécanos 17 france va être joué dans
femmes non mais en plus il ya un truc
juste pour dire comme ça dans la
position qui est valable pour les noirs
en fait c'est que bon petit rock tu vois
que ces choix faire monde et j'attache 6
en l'air c'est hyper dur et même si tu
fais grand roque un jour tu apprendras
faut être quatre ou h3 était
complètement braqué quoi mais je pense
est vraiment un avantage quasi décisif
un faux faux faux enfin football et le
noir pour résister et puis c'est très
dur avec les noirs ça va être chaud mais
c'était le meilleur coup de l'ordi non
je crois que c'est kiev 4 lumière
couleur dit ouais on sait pas c'est un
ordi ico plus soit on met deux façons
dam des deux dames ces deux tout ce
qu'on avait fouillé tu continues un peu
tu es très bien la question sait plus
comment enfin la vraie question je pense
est née peau est ce qu'il va trouver ya
peut-être qu'une ou deux manières de
jouer qui permet de ne pas perdre sur le
champ et pétitions sait plus comment les
pauvres à se dépatouiller puisque maxime
var sans que n'importe quoi qu'ils
fassent ce soit toujours bien d'être à
survient neuf
la question c'est plutôt qu'elle cette
app nova mettre en place ces tables de
maxime qui met la d'amendé de ces deux
il fait grand comme l'a dit fabia le fou
qui revient h3 on l'avait en avait parlé
il ya le cas mais les clients f4 tout va
ou de fous enfin tu veux non mais c'est
ça le faisait 4 tab à 1 comme cette
diagonale du choix je trouve madame
ashton jouer au hockey
il joue vite un nom mais avant ça il
sait faire nombreux badauds massés en
fait c'est un coût normal juste eu
d'état d'âme sont enlevées je la lis
bien le passage pour le grand roque donc
damas 5 e te dire c'est logique on
serait bien le rock avec les blancs ils
nous disent que c'est un mauvais coup
oui mais bon disons que tu as la
réputation c'est peut-être cavaliers f4
de nouveau et maxime n'a pas joué aux
précédents on comprend qu'après dame ces
deux dames à 5,44 pas spécialement mieux
qu'aux coups précédents faut pas trop
regarder l'ordi damas 5 pourquoi pas
après je pense c'est pas idiot pour les
peaux de jouer vite
voilà pour la peine d'habitude je
critique mais pour ce moment là je pense
que c'est pas si idiots qui peut être
mal autant hors du temps la pendule
ouais
l'investigation si tu te mets à
réfléchir tube sicotte battait mal
partout donc toute façon tu vas pas
trouvé un truc bien tu vas encore plus
énervé ça à voir ton visage peut-être
mieux jouer vite et vaya con dios quoi
on lui fout des deux autres bateaux si
ce n'est pas toujours envie de faire
spontanément je comprends il est
peut-être mettre la dame en a 6 je peux
comprendre en fait des coups de feu 5 4
mois tu qu'on se démarquer qua non mais
clairement mes joueurs je peux
comprendre enfin je peux comprendre
l'idée après je vais faire le cinquième
cas tu vas être beaucoup mieux c'est sûr
mais non mais ce que fait nico je
comprends mais c'est fait il va jouer
une partie et il va bien se battre mais
il a déjà trop fait de mal à sa position
après quatre coups quoi de ce jeu là
c'est l'impressionnant pas c'est une
nouvelle fois sur des quatre répondent
cavaliers f6 nom qui est encore au tmb
la juste après hcap tu te fais autre
chose tu peux pas rejouer la même que tu
as déjà il ya trois mois et qui est
mauvaise parce qu'objectivement ces
moments juste maxime j'ai un truc tu as
plus sympathiques ou non mais j'en
rigole et on tue à moi qui suis un
joueur de slaves ont apprécié un peu
influencé mais fera peut-être ces six
pour faire des 5 et me dire que vous la
vendre la slave avec g6 schlechter jeu
pas comment s'appelle just a ouais mais
ça ressemble à des trucs qu'on fait ça
tous accueillir une folle 200h car en
fait jusqu'ici 3 où les blancs blancs 16
oui mais bon peu importe alors qu'alizé
3 des 5 h 4 c'est une ligne etc si c'est
une option ou quoi mais gers et paca
table pour les blancs oui mais tu peux
aussi vous fin tu vas plein de trucs
mais meilleur que tu peux te dire que
c'est 4 h 4 ces pastilles aux dents tu
feras des fois des cdc des fous g5 comme
ça non mais j'essaie toujours enfin je
donne juste une idée de quelqu'un qui
joue pas la grille d'un voyage à droite
je sais si si si voilà c'est juste
mission sur table plein doute à droite
mais ils doivent préparer mieux que ça
contre ce contrat chez un gros jeu d'il
ya six mois de cela les sept mois de ça
peux tu as tu peux juste méprisés et à
dire oui bon c'est un coup de mer et
algues et ou guerrier mais qu'il l'a
jouée à de nombreuses reprises c'est pas
anodin
et puis critique on sait que c'est un
mec qui à la recherche absolue de la
vérité si le jour où on sait que c'est
qu'il a trouvé des trucs on le connaît
le greenwich le fait qu'ils le jouent
bas c'est peut-être que d'autres ont
tous leur jouer au hockey c'est que
c'est possible on ne peut pas prendre le
truc par dessus la jambe et une petite
ligne plus comme ça non mais je suis
100% d'accord enfin je suis choquée en
fait part dans le match sérieux de
l'ouverture non mais je suis assez
choqué par le niveau de jeu en général
sur cette demi finale
je trouve que c'est quand même pop tonio
de ce nom mais la préparation à
l'ouverture aujourd'hui fab ça fait
quand même partie intégrante du niveau
de jeu à haut niveau
quand même vu que je vous sais pas 1963
mais dont je suis quand même choqué que
à ce niveau de la compétition les
joueurs cavac ce qu'on lui fait c'est
bien fait le boulot
c'est lui qui a attrapé nebbou
aujourd'hui ignorant la monnaie de sa
pièce quoi bon faut pas craquer un nom
mais il faut la gagner c'est pas style
simple mais je veux juste pas rêver
mieux on demande si le mcs sera pas
favori demain
c'est vraiment dur à dire je pense mais
mathieu qui nous dit quoi faute de da
vinci 2,5 par quelque 400 à capter mais
il ya fou des trois dames siens kiev 17
quai des cinq avocats de madame à 6 e 5
fu des trois intermédiaires ouais comme
c'est un risque sur dame b 3 pouces et 4
et dams et de foot est roi et j'essayais
de comprendre bahout adam et rohff c'est
quand tu prends m6 aussi à nombre de
tours alors attends dames c'est un bon
peu importe ce qu'ils disent est évoqué
10 puis on prend web adam là au moins
les quatre chemins à se doit de plus ou
moins majority barre des 10/1 je pense
qu'il faut h36 des mâles de jeudi un
homme déçu sous mes jeux près d'oujda
soir madame décision peut pas y aller en
bus et une dame en acier tout cas assez
joli l'amarante à dire c'est beau ça
d'autres une belle manne en finir issou
ouais ouais ouais mais faute et de
maxime qui a fait car il y avait quatre
gros écoute barrette ses coups que ce
soit +10 est prise elle feint une roue
en f1
j'aurais pu jouer comme ça ils
s'enlèvent du clonage oui oui mais bon
il prendra dame assise sur échec
c'est bizarre va ok tu ne sais pas si tu
vas faire vos sales gosses qui sont peut
être mais je trouve ça parle mais tonga
et b17 c'est le couffin bonjour ça
marche où vas tu vas dit je sais pas qui
a été 5 que j'allais faire ce que je ne
vous ferais cliquer c3 et après je sais
faire aussi
que je te prends mon idée c'est que j'ai
dû damas qui rôdent à mélanger 6 ouais
pardon
du coup j'ai fait recaler fuite mais
sûrement prise je suis là bas c'est leur
show quoi tourner fait un bon roi fo qui
bon sens qui est du jeu va faire un
grand oui plutôt non mais c'est l'idée
maxime c'est de faire au 5e 6,5 ses
joueurs j'étais je me lave vaisselle
mois encore attends je vendais ça à
gemma j'ai laissé leurs dix cavaliers b4
intermédiaire pour caler des cinq ok
c'est hyper logique ok ça c'est logique
du coup cavada ce petit truc triki que
mama temps et un truc qui est chiant la
sexy fait grand croix baby 3,8 en fait
c'est ok ça m'amène à me cacher quoi
mais ok mais ce que né pouvait pas en
train de garde régler un problème de sa
position je dis pas que max est moins
bien ou koala et max reste beaucoup
mieux mais j'avais ce que n'est peau est
pas en train de rendre le truc un peu
plus vivable qui a dix minutes bas
peut-être ouais non médicaux qui avait
très grande des jeunes cavaliers ans et
7 il va être bien parce qu'il va mais un
v6 bon après grand tout prend des cinq
ans et may cry assiste plutôt mieux j'en
fais tous pareils ça je pense à beaucoup
ok c est premier comment dire c'est
maxime qui a frappé il ya eu une grosse
droite enfin mais je veux pas que ça re
phase du joshua ruiz tu as là je suis à
qui tape un peu au début puis après ça
j'ai pas envie de voir un et pour votre
jugement vaudreuil mais pourtant il a
fait à ce sujet c'est ce que je souhaite
en finir là c'est pour ça que j'ai peur
mais je n'ai pas dit de manière anodine
en fait par un fou c'est un peu ruiz est
ce que quoi sert de jouer nous proposera
trois baies carey mais ce qui me fait
peur c'est qu'il prend les corps et
biens ouais mais fan jam ntic sept bébés
katché damas six je récupère quand même
un tempo et mon cavalier c'est cette île
contrôle des gaz ultra important de
chic et non en fait c'est j'attends
l'opinion du grand maître enfin
j'attends ton approbation coiffard non
mais ça peut l'être est agréé très
agréable pour les noirs mais n'hésita
pas fait rage ces trucs concrets font
oublier qu'il ya un pion de plus ok il
faut des deux c'était vraiment un truc
qui avait l'air très très chiant plus
que ça mais là bon ça reste ça n'est pas
un problème à long terme dont le centre
mais juste oui tout à l'heure fabien il
voulait faire flasher trois fois f
qu'adrian qu'on regarde et pourra viser
le roi maintenant quand tu fais grand
roque ya le carillon f4 qui empêchent ou
f4 ya plus fois je crois disons que il
est moins aux abois quoi c'est ça c'est
ça
au moins visuellement et la e-lettre une
parade contre 5 go si c'est déjà quelque
chose
un truc tactique expo québec quatre
intermédiaires qui nous dit je rêve de
me tuer a trouvé quatre excès mais c'est
logique aussi on aime bien se faire peur
avec mais bataillon c'est logique quand
on a envie de fermer quatre baies 5
quand tu auras un grand qui va arriver
mais je vous dise que mathieu est
d'accord sur le fait que ce soit moins
quand même
clair que tout à l'heure outre lors d un
jeune héros non mais c'est pas
malheureux dont je suis ce qu'il ya de
plus en plus de monde et que voilà on
est nombreux à coeur et merci à azouz
migri 13 pour le prime est juste voie
que le chat est très nombreux et on sent
que la communauté des échecs vidéo truc
avec nous mais juste quand on a des
petites communautés machin tu as encore
le temps de prendre le temps de discuter
avec tout le monde de machins et où la
face et arrière un message toutes les
trois secondes quoi dire là n'est ce pas
fameuse non mais du coup c'est dur
d'être à la fois les dessous chics et
sur le tchat son copain food et 3 tu
laisses avec tempo c'est pas très humain
ça c'est humain et non non aucune
rupture mais en fait moi j'aurais plutôt
joué avec dante de mathieu et fois je
crois fouet 4 persos mais ça va je crois
que que 1
beaucoup de bouchons fidh et max midi
les blancs ne vont pas gagner ça pour
moi oui ça va bien se passer quand même
on espère que ça va gagner bien se
passer
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer
je regarde juste les paumes nains ne
varie suis un peu oui après c'est vrai
que mathieu a raison enfin si tu regarde
maintenant la lune numéro 1 à leurs 10 à
aix et à trois roues en f1 relève de a3
à b 4 enfin c'est avec ce que c'est mais
je crois qu'ils veulent jouer c'est même
pas un truc d'ordi parce que 84 envie de
le faire il a fait à 3 way et eux at on
enfin tu vas laisser tous les jours
quand on lit des tourtes son méga tu as
tu veux pas tu as besoin que la tour
soit défendu et donc fait juste meneboo
par contre j'ai peut-être aussi
s'éjecter rock alors à temps il a il a
rejoué tempo que'il c7 vous qui veut pas
des cons à venir tant les fab rejouer
thème fois sur sept
évidemment tout ce qu'il fait c'est fou
il est complètement fou cet homme est
fou en fait non mais il va finir la
partie sens thann genre à abandonner le
tas ne va pas tenir aux questions web
des images et 5 et cavaliers 6 mai on
peut pas dû qu'à l'est du pays quatre
dans la douleur intermédiaire dégagé
nerveuse vedette perdait 80 stands
oui bon on va dire que sur b4 sont ils
faits d'armes assez j'aurais fait roi
vieux je me dis je compense par rev 2
pour enfin louis où je peux commencer
par je ne sais pas je peux tout faire
quoi mais bon la race et six mineurs
alors soit ils craquent et il nous fait
une haie mais elle n'est poster je joue
tout tempo parce que j'ai trop de
pression et je tiens pas soit il est
tard et nos militants soient je sais pas
en fait il est quand même complètement
fou la vraie c'était bien le cas et
c'est cette affaire me paraît pas permis
les premiers coups de l'ordi laisse pas
max rêver respirer enfin je comprends là
par exemple c'est être un cas de figure
où ça se passe plutôt bien sa stratégie
en réalité mais mais le truc qu'on veut
dire c'est que enfin une fois sur quatre
il va filer une pièce en paca mais les
contres maxima est il que fil des ans
contre un an de 1,5 de file jean zay
beaucoup d'ailleurs fait les jours où tu
gaffe pas évidemment on va dire oui très
bien joué tu a maintenu la pression sur
l'adversaire c'était fantastique mais
une fois sur cinq
tu as donné une pièce en un a pas de
chances face c'est complètement fou
c'est complètement
mais bravo algérie les courageux il sut
ses convictions on l'appelle tempo ni
achi dans le tchat
ben écoute bon il met la pression autant
après ça et encore une heure pour maxime
en fait on peut pas dire qu'il soit si
longue samax ah non mais je dirais que
c'est au delà de la pression autant fab
c'est plus une pression physique entre
guillemets c'est toujours d'autres
joueurs tu peux être baladés tu veux tu
peux pas relâcher la pénurie en ce sens
là pour cette partie précise vu la
position c'est peut-être pasillo que ça
parce qu'il est vrai qu'il est mal joue
pas des si mauvais coup maxime qui
peuvent si côté il ne laisse pas quelle
musique d'antan ali soient bien
comprendre qu'une fois sur cinq c'est
beaucoup trop à son niveau ouest sabre
d'or je suis d'accord mais peut-être que
dans ce truc précis là il se dit toute
façon il ya 80% de chances de perdre et
que du coup fait s'il fait une gaffe
c'est pas dans le ratio s'était pas si
grave
tu vois ce que je veux dire fab non mais
là impossible on consent puisqu'il ne
fait pas il était pas si souvent on est
5 e voici tout juste s'est-il avec la
manche aînés les conneries
complètement en fait non mais là c'est
vrai ce qui est bien c'est qu'avec les
bons tu peux jouer tranquille préparer
toi et tes trucs pas obligé d'aller
directement dans le concret je monte ton
roi du québec à toutes et tous au centre
d'après moi ce qui m'inquiète fat c'est
peut-être que les gens ont trop mis de
like ait trop de retweet pour qu'elle ne
gagne ça peut être le problème
alors est-ce qu'on peut risquer pour la
position ennemie avec les blancs bottes
très simple les blancs ou le centre et
les noirs ont aucune rupture pour le cas
c'est exactement si tu fais ces cinq au
pire y aura des 5 et sa créature basset
vice versa avec f 5 5
donc bon ça avance pas grand chose donc
les blancs déjà tel centre ça te permet
de voir les pièces qui bouge bien et
contre les castrais importante aux
principes de base aux échecs mais c'est
toujours bon à rappeler
et du coup tu peux devrait comme tu as
envie le roi dénonce ces patrouilles 20
tirs a que ça reste un souci parce que
et déjà la tourache 1 qui joue tu as
déjà le fou etc et grands arcs va
sûrement prendre b4 b5 qui va vraiment
une autre est ouvert aux citrons donc
pour toutes ces raisons la cie chant et
qui aurait rejoint en fait ils trouvent
pas de plans très constructif et des
blancs peu je plains de full tilt justin
roy f2b queyrat remettre les tours au
mieux préparé e 5 e ce qui se passe très
très bien arriver parce que tu va casser
le pion à vii il a g6 très faible juste
5 trop vite
t'as pas envie que tu donnes même la
case des 5 pour les cavaliers noirs il
s'est préparé à ça n'est pas justement
avec son son chai marqué 6 7 6
mais bon en gros il est juste là ici de
résister mais avec les blancs ça c'est
tranquille c'est assez bien comme
pression et ça me fait penser à une
blague le petit rock groc pile tu perds
face je gagne un support à droite juste
battu par la gauche ce bateau si c'est
pas de chance quoi et du coup il faut
que tu restes sur la tranche quoi serait
beaucoup il a réussi à résister en
restant sur la tranche de la pièce à
laurent blanc qui le roi blanc et pas
très sexy oui mais comment tu le touches
mais c'est un peu comme bruit soit fin
bah en fait le roi blanc il est il
explosifs at il ouvert mais comme les
blancs l'espace sont les pièces bien
placé c'est pas les noirs khattak non
pas du tout en fait j'ai pas comment
dire c'est comme transit indienne si je
vais jouer la mardelle pétrole mais
voilà je suis à cannes et où je la
cherchais août on a cet ancien nom la
bouche que en fait quand même très
attention comment tu vois moi je
m'appelais marlène schiappa sur ce chat
là c'est comme chercher une estonienne
que je prenne quoi une anglaise aussi
une italienne fin joueur c'est quoi ce
délire la femme qu'est ce tu fais femmes
on est surtout non c'est dépassé la fab
à temps
une espagnole une machin c'était quand
même capricieux quoi on tu prends ce
qu'on me donne envie hein du coup mar
del plata
ouais une argentine d'une argentine
david avoue viser une au pied levé une
commande car il ya huit mois à venir on
crie on va dire non mais c'est juste
pour hogan fcf 3 kg 5
ok peu importe en fait là les noirs vous
dire où ils auront à débattre et ça il
faut qu'on sait tous les pions et du
coup il peut se faire attaquer alors
qu'on aura un maximum f1 est en fait
c'est pas les blancs qui vont attaquer
sur l'ale dames du relais droit je veux
dire dans cette dans la pression
d'entrée
c'est les noirs qui vont pousser les
pièges les pions 1 et les cavaliers en j
6 1 et 6 3 cette fois depuis sept mois
que c'était un acheteur à quoi mais si
l'histoire des espaces ça compte en fait
et donc pour revenir un an au direct
alors que c'est donc le roi
effectivement la bonde do il n'y a pas
trop de temps à chercher mais vu que ces
gens sont bien placés qui ont l'espace
pour être martias ya aucun personnes qui
attaquent 10,3 blanche alors est-ce que
j'ai 5 justement comment se pose cette
question attaque le cavalier admettons
qu avait lieu de et g4 peut être une
idée fab en se disant
j'attaque le centre ben pour coup pour
coup après peut-être que tu as juste
heureux dirigeants du cavalier g3 kf5 ou
faire tourner autour grafika trop je
sais pas mais ça ne sont pas idiots a
priori scarlett vu tout ce qu'on dit que
les avantages des blancs c'est le centre
que leurs ouailles protéger g5 g4 pour
miner le pion f3 ouvrir l'oeil droit et
attaquer le point 4 ça paraît qu'à
mettre la réponse logique si ça marche
d'un point de vue concret attention aux
fab ne me fait pas dire ce que j'ai pas
dis je prend des pincettes quand je
commente attention euh non mais c'est
pas m après six tours j'ai machin c'est
vrai que les blancs aussi peu joué tour
à g1 ils essaient sur l'icône tu as une
sorte de là et tu feras grand roque
fouet non mais enfin là pour le coup je
trouve pas ça du tout sûr de leur
gestion du g4 donc quelque part tu m'as
double jeu nouveau merci ce que j'ai
déjà commandé ponant jeunes donc donc
donc
pour écoute ça semble ça sent quand même
bien parti mais je suis un poil moins
confiants qui a qui a trente quarante
minutes fab
non non non ok on aime se sont assignés
pour après une heure de jeu avant un
truc comme ça
j'ai cinq logique mais un tronc f5 dit
matthieu reeb 1 c'est un peu comme
murray mais c'est une robe jenny grand
bal en verre donc forcément c'est bien
joué mais c'est vrai que je pense parce
que en fait si tu fais rien tu vas te
faire écraser petit à petit et est en
fait ok tu fais le tronc f5 bombe a fait
35 commis ça donne un peu de contre jeu
un truc à faire donc on nous dit vu la
vitesse ou une épaule joue en partie
landes il est redoutable en lice weill
est redoutable et truc c'est que maxime
une autre table aussi donc à nous de te
dire là si tu veux c'est c'est une
bataille entre un pitbull et il ya quoi
comme race de chien très méchant trop de
valeur
ouais voilà cc pitbull contrat devait
leur 6e place et tu ne sais pas lequel
est le plus méchant non mais d'ailleurs
match conseil mais plutôt meierhans
rapide mais mais c'est trop dur trop de
soucis qui est vraiment dire qui va
gagner mais ce rêve ou quoi de faire
comme l'année il se rappelle et des
sagnes on a souvent parlé des matchs de
foot entre les éléphants et les castors
suisse qu'ils font des taupes et très
sains et saufs sont très fortes bah ils
attaquent scooter des soldats venus de
partout et ça y est les écrits et opel
était monstrueuse ait eu prennent le
ballon ils vont sous terre et tata
énormément de mal mais après il savait
plus trop dans quels buts marqués nancy
c'est leur problème mais chez ce truc en
fait un méchant c'est le problème des
topos et scarlett elles sont un peu
aveugle et you've heard elle sortait de
terre et sait pas trop dans quel de quel
côté du but elle devait tu vois et c'est
un peu leurs défauts mais c'est vrai
qu'en terme de possession de balle elle
domine complètement abattu voir la joie
fut le ballon guillaume guillon en tout
cas c'est un beau match aux échecs ça
n'arrive pas si souvent
non c'est vrai ça joue ça peut être des
nuls insipides dans les parties lentes
on va pas se plaindre de ce match plein
sauf que quand on est mené 1 0 mais
sinon en terme de deux parties de
suspens de tout ça c'est que l'on nous
demande si elle peut battre manu silva
au candidat alors l'avantagé c'est que
magnus ne jouera pas les candidats vous
faut gagner les candidats et après je
m'amuse après doha et willy peu la
procédure enfin il sera pas favori six
cas de figure arrive mais je m'étais pas
largué fait intacte même des chances des
chances de le mettre
donc où van velde doit-il placer ses
tours sa dépense qui joue si fait j'ai 5
g k comme si les femmes cette paille de
fer tour des maîtres sur les sur les
colonnes à la loi si l'autre fait grand
roc sera peut-être pas idiot de faire
plus tôt les tours
face du roi ça dépend vraiment du jeu
noirs ici le train pendant le dans la
réponse est ce que vlad est plutôt pour
max ou pour n'est pas plutôt pour mac
cela parce que parce qu'il nous aime
bien et l'avenir la chaîne il aime bien
la france et les français d'ailleurs je
profite longtemps plutôt pas trop mal
avec ma faim et ils seront onze autres
amis non plus mais je dirige vraiment
pas drôle selon mark herman il est pour
maxi si vous êtes et coéquipier en
équipe de france assez longtemps et
c'est un jazz et navy glycérique
humaniste a réussi à se qualifier pour
les candidats qu'une seule fois réveillé
il serait depuis on le voit que candidat
preuve donc voilà ou d'un moment tu te
dis être meilleur joueur du monde tu ne
joues pas les candidats ou es-tu là de
nouveau ne va pas légion en 2020 magnus
carlsen boudent le boubou de les
candidats c'est alors sur grand qu'il
n'y a pas de problème avec eux 5 kg cinq
icônes allons sur puits b 4b 5b ans il
ya un grand roque p4p sent que c'est
l'idée genre tu vas faire des quatre
fers damas si c'était des cinq séances
qui doit calculer qui est tombé cinq
épreuves et 5,2 me prend b5 et b6 et d5
et oui bon allez quoi jour h c'est un
pas assez l'idée on reçoit quand on veut
et tour oui ça fait face et ça a l'air
très bien pour les blancs voilà du coup
elle serait mieux placé en bien c'est un
cran a changé de nom mais je pense que
vraiment dépôt il doit jouer le geste
inquiets compagnie parce que quoi
d'autre non mais tu vois un peu mobilisé
les pièces allèles droit à mathon
allèles damas préfigure un fou et
peut-être après contre-attaqué hausse en
mai g5 g4 bon nous aurait fait tempo on
l'aurait joué depuis bien longtemps
ban ou en fait on se serait dit
différemment fab des cas très malin
empêche g5 non plus le mac sont déjà
jaugées 4 donc je te met sur la bonne
route
j'ai dit que tu dois réagir absolument
ravi on veut pas laisser le monopole des
g4 g5 rfi au deuxième coup quand même je
fais g6 quoi je ne peux pas faire j'ai
cinq gérants soupçon que d'une case mais
avec l'espoir plus tard de pouvoir faire
j'ai cinq femmes danger 5 c'est vraiment
logique pour la peine allez le joueur
français donc
guilbaud siffert damas six et temporise
et non tu peux tu tu anticipes b4 b5 et
tu dit est sur b4 tu fais dame c4 ça se
fait une idée aussi genre pour presser
la dame devant et anticiper un peu les
baies 5 n'ont d'ailleurs ne trouve pas
je vais 4 trop vite sur le massif
probablement plus tôt avait calculé le
sac calculer l oued et coûteuse pour
c'est un tour g5 jouer parfois les gens
disent pourquoi vous disposiez la partie
à mais il écoute la chaîne qua non mais
c'est juste très logique d'écouté la
chaîne gouffre et moi aussi mais
d'autres jugés sains mais c'est un peu
comme le bessin qui r2 max en fait c'est
que en fait tu vois que tu étais
compressé et tu dois trouver un truc un
moment on nous propose qu'un voyage
saint jean richert je travaille à
changer même pas pensé 5tourcoing cinq
gros rock et à quoi ça sert vidal et il
a une aventure f5 pour t'ouvrir sa série
lâche 5 c'est horrible non ont voulu
reculer
soit qu'il ait trois ou quatre c'est le
cas des 2 kg 3 kiev 500 bien
en mai dépôt a peint la séquence de quoi
quand même plutôt favorable à un impôt
depuis la sortie de l'ouverture mais il
a deux chanteuses de tous ces problèmes
mais en tout cas il y les parkings
bondés 84,2 le tempo ok ok donc attend
faut toujours regarder ces trucs là mais
là il n'y a que deux pièces avec le deux
pièces mais j'aime pour conseil pour les
amateurs quand on vous attaque la dame
et qui a des prêts sans prise jeter
quand même toujours un oeil aux prises
on sait jamais que ça fasse assez de
matos bon la dame assise c'est
complètement forcé au quai d'alger si
c'est juste idiot que qui tu vas faire
là mais non madame et ses cavaliers eux
deux ou alors il est venu en d35
mesdames c4 à mesdames scat à cavaillon
singles when je comprends en damas y
jouer bon tempo
j'ai envie de dire pour avoir tiré que
doukha usmh un des trains n'a ni bazzo
qui vient d'arriver dit la veille ça dit
quoi ça dit que c'est chaud plutôt
intéressant pour maxime les amis plutôt
intéressant pour mac cette partie qui
arrive à surprendre en fin d'année
passée au tout surpris que j'aurais dû
dire et il a du jeu alors après midi
faire compliqué il ya une association
etc
je pense pas que v5 soit une idée en
demandant le chat je pense est
prématurée tant que le roi par ok bah je
sais pas ou qu'on leur impose je ne me
l'expliqué pas se lancer pour éviter
qu'il y ait des 3 et les ide à la base
de dames c4 mais la sueur dams et 4,60 à
cavalier ou cinq ans quoique tam 6 et je
sais pas femmes
je suis étonné par la défense de
nespouls quand même je trouve que il
joue assez bien calé trois là bas je
trouve que là la séquence parce qu'il
faut quand même souligner on nous dit là
dans le chat que l' avantage de maxime
c'est un peu réduit mais faut souligner
un truc c'est que dans la position qui
avait une épaule trouver des coûts qui
perdent pas en sur le champ c'est assez
difficile
hélas était en train de réaliser des
pauses cdu c'est vraiment du très haut
niveau fab non le court en jouant vite
bonjour vite non mais c'est fabre
souligner quand les mecs jouent mal ou
quoi mais là je trouve que le niveau de
jeu de n'est pas aujourd'hui est
carrément supérieur même à celui d'hier
ce qui arriva quand même enfin il un peu
spoil un truc gagnon au début maxime a
re spoilé il a fini en trouvant deux
coups durs live ou une position tu peux
perdre en 22 coutu peut être rentrer
chez toi on est au 20e coup il est dans
la game va signer pour venait à se
qualifier en faisant nul ici il aura
vraiment mérité sa qualif parce qu'il
sera sorti d'un truc surtout contré
nouvelle meilleur joueur en tactique et
dans les positions bordélique du monde
il aura mérité il méritera vraiment sa
place signer pour la gagne compte
d'auteur non mais il est loin d'être
sorti d'affaires il va la perdre et puis
il est pauvre voilà pas non plus il m a
rien du tout du coup je dis juste que
s'ils se sortait de cette partie ce
serait une performance majuscule c'est
parce que sortir d'une partie comme ça
qu'on traîne nouvelle c'est ultra dur
fab tout ce que j panne on aurait eu
nettement tu vois comme des fois on
critique un petit peu les joueurs ou
quoi moi celle là après cette position
là je passe pas le 20e pas je pense qu
17/18 que j'abandonne vraiment et femmes
sans vouloir te manquer de respect tu
passes pas le 25e contre elles viennent
non non on traduit le jour et hetian
gagner après vingt coups très facilement
peut-être contre vlad j'aurais souffert
un petit peu mais pas rentrer mais l
amafi lille mais il n'a rien fait de
funés peau mais en fait si justement
c'est qu'il ya tellement de kumo 20 qui
les a tous et vite c'est hyper dur c'est
genre telle marche quelque part et il
n'y a qu'un pas sur cinq qui est bon à
chaque fois ils te trouve le seul pas
qu'il reste
donc il a fait tour à c'est un max bon
il a encore juste pour dire alors dit tu
te dis que cavalier 17 et le seul coût
qui reste encore un peu dans la
normalité le reste c'est bien pour les
blancs oui ça reste bien pour les blancs
quand même mais j'ai recueilli 17 c'est
hyper dur à jouer ici bah oui et non la
légèreté tenté par chèque à traiter par
le grand jacques
non mais gros que tu crois qu'on a
compris que ça allait pas quoi oui
madame b deux dames se retremper l'as tu
fais b saint caprais battue va
l'éliminer grant rées mais c'est beau
depuis tout à l'heure de deux avoir
compris que c'était si grave et donc un
goût tu peux faire précédemment 6 6 mais
à titre encaissé 5 d'hommes si vite
qu'elle c'est logique ça 6,5 me ok pas
su prendre cinq ou six hommes justice
notre aussi ce faire quatre cas et
disent leur tour mais bon quand bien
même tu as pour moi ce qui perdure de
comprendre c'est ce que c'est pourquoi
ça c'est pire que fin je trouve ça
toujours très dur fab de comprendre mais
c'est ce que galfond dit dans son
bouquin la la positionner à une plaie
que le plus dur aux échecs c'est quand
tu as une position pour icta cinq
variantes mauvaise qui en a quatre qui
perdent et une qui va et c'est ultra
ultra ultra difficile de décider
laquelle est la bonne
non mesdames aussi ce tu peux regarder
c'est mais ok bon tokyo
ok tu vois tout électrique il mais je
sais pas tu peux regarder c'est un des
coups candidats aux dames aussi gkp tu
peux regarder parce que c'était ton
l'idée de base est qu'à et 17 pour
justement éviter etc et c5 qui avait
lieu 5 tu peux rien aussi parce qu'en
plus ça donne l'option de faire f 5 un
jour way est peut-être mal je peux dire
aux 15 jours et asphalt 5 sur 5 et 10
oui je faire des dessins rifains de
faire son âge et pas un goût
d'ordinateurs débile c'est ça les trois
coups que tu regardais ces dames aussi
ce qui est des seuls dégâts
oui en juillet c'est son boulot de
calculer pour porter de l'eau à son
moulin femme quand tu fais grand roque
h5 lui demande même ce n'est pas le roi
noir qui va commencer à être bien et
laurent blanc dans le viseur de la tour
et la tunisien qui est parti du mauvais
côté nantes a raison tf1 femmes
je suis enfin nous venons mais après je
sais pas quelles couches sociales dans
la partie mais ce serait sûrement un
coup que je pourrais regarder ses 17 ça
me semble pas encline à tresques non
c'est regardable et en plus tu mets à
ceux des cartes quand même rien fait
c'est hyper logique mais c'est comme
toujours ce que tu m'expliquer hier
femmes c'est que quand tu regardes avec
l'ordi tout paraît logique
non tout roule explications au foot je
vous mets en vente aux locaux en fin
d'après tu fais du vlad commente aussi
réfléchir j'aurais souhaité m
est-ce qu'on va suivre n'est peu voyou
navarra ciné pop aabar bien sûr ciné pop
hasna varane et pau ce serait un match
décisive encore plus que celui là
jusqu'à la dernière chance donc
évidemment on serait là samedi dimanche
rapt et la force qu'il ya besoin chl un
a priori pas besoin
bordel j'ai le droit d'avoir fait avec
moi quand même tu veux dire si des
trench et nous fait un caca bas 2 2 et
censée être là pour max quoi ouais mais
mon ranch où il va conclure on va même
pas lui dire max est encore longue
non mais on va lui dire on est va je
vais lui dire gg
j'ai écrit quand même sur le mail à
mourenx où je lui dirai n'y joue on suit
jusqu'à ce que masquer la qualification
de macgé paris paddy conçu et max
matches à jouer on suit sa qualif aux
candidats à l'isf éliminé maintenant sa
qualif au candidat doit jouer en finale
j'ai même pas besoin de lui car en fait
à rennes joue on va lui dire orange où
ce taux peut pas sinon tu viens récurer
les shots le jargon le contrat a été
signé
genre le contrat était signé j'ai écrit
je la preuve d'une au fait qu à lui
faire une vidéo fasse quand même à la
gouge décor plus tard le même crâne que
gouverner quoi tu vois le contrat est
signé
je t'attends dans le gange quoi j'aurais
quand même faire très attention le
renshaw là va falloir elle va par fauré
1 mais la joie qui qui est 17
je me sens bien et paul il commence à
m'énerver l'année peau il va falloir
qu'ils reçoivent un appel du président
de la russie contre est un con tu as tu
vas tu avais eu à gérer il faut avoir
les bonnes je sais pas si je sais pas
combien de gens dans le chat on la réf
allez viens on essaye dans le chatt
combien combien on la rêve de lever le
doigt qui à la réf
je pense qu'on a pas des masses
j'ai avalé un très très peu très peu de
gens qui ont la réveille toi de quel réf
l'aref la rave des de forêt les chiottes
[Musique]
elle est allée très élitiste non
invasive la salle prouvant qu'ils
connaissent tony peu de le dire c'est
qu'on soit plus vraiment avec femme et
tous y as tu la dernière quitte mon dieu
les gens qui écrivent telle culture la
pop culture
finalement c'est même elle qui va être
sous pression mais yannick même tout
d'un coup un seul nom mais pour cette
partie quoi qu'il en soit je voudrais
surtout pas à pas les accabler max
vraiment pas qu'il fait lui aussi une
grosse partie mais surtout siné pauvres
menaçant sortir juste tirer le chapeau
année pour salah pour autant ce que
donne pas de noms mais ya pas de travaux
comme le critiquer pour son ouverture
coquitlam ça changera prix non mais bon
fan de toute façon tu es nul tu ne sais
pas jouer aux échecs
tu vas te faire éliminer par navarra
tellement tu ne sais pas où il va se
prendre tous les trucs de base inquiète
pas mais juste pour cette partie là on
pourra dire tu as bien joué une fois
dans ta vie tu as pu toucher le niveau
de vlad sur 10 coups sur les 25 ou de ta
partie bon qu'est ce qu'on peut faire un
bon là on a des quatre attaques et déjà
pour lire ici je comprends pas c'est une
partie live allow est complètement
complètement brûlés
rodolphe une partie live c'est en ce
moment même à jérusalem
on n'est pas sur place ouais non mais là
ils feront en tenant franchement dépôt
le truc avec damas cinq étoiles a
vraiment bien joué tellement dur ce qui
la fait tu as c'est vraiment ce qui me
blesse le plus chez les joueurs du haut
niveau à plus de 2007 c'est pas la
manière dont ils gagnent les parties
quand ils sont mieux isolés sont
durables de défendre c'est
impressionnant c'est impressionnant
je pense qu'un voile car ils pourraient
la dona topalov ce serait une sorte de
petit finish comme krainik violence qui
trollent gullit rôles sociaux
d'ailleurs je compte faire un tweet ou
là faudra des retweets si jamais né peut
se qualifier ou quoi je pense que samedi
on va faire un tweet fajou et oui
théâtre fédération russe en leur
demandant de revoir leur politique j'ai
déjà trouvé en fait ce que je leur
demandais je leur demande et d'organiser
un match alex et nkm vesle pour la wild
card et je pense que si on arrive à 500
voire 1000 retweet on est une micro
chances que ça aboutisse de mecs sont
sueur c'est bon ouais parce qu'ils
peuvent avoir peur de l'image
elle est rousse kof ça peut se mit
marché il ya une toute petite chance
d'être 5%
oui ça marche un rassemblement pas mais
je pense qu'on peut tenter ça dans tous
les cas au pire on fout la merde on sera
juste un petit clash en plus ce benoît
sont leurs points hhonors n'est un pib
de bastia est la dame du coup comme ça l
attaque plus la casse dope syndicats
ouais ouais les gars des casses par un
sage 3 s'intéressant à travers le tough
que oui bon comme ce soir on fera jamais
ça et il a rempli aucune condition non
bond à monsieur jean bon et on il a joué
dam des trois peut-être intéressant ça
s'est ouvert à sa pop et house hasard
sur leur dit non mais au lieu de les
vidéos doivent aussi ce qu'est lieu de
la richesse car au lieu de jouer notre
chance bombe
non mais ça a l'air encore bien pour max
faut arrêter à dire 00 00 j'ai laissé
les croire c'est pas 00 ça les mecs ses
avantages mais encore sans aucun doute
tu menaces des cinq quand même encore
annoncé mais n'est-ce pas parce qu'il y
avait deux en l'air à la fin ok mais tu
restes tu viens ici je suis tellement
sûr que maxime va la gagner c'est
finalement
c'est plutôt quand même dans toutes les
étapes dont je dirige est un petit coup
de j'ai eu un petit coup de mou parce
que mais non mais la position qu'il ya
plus ou moins qu'un seul coup jouable
pas introuvable serra que c'est ça ouais
mais personne toujours acquise et que tu
as 30 kg 3 qui avait des f-5 tu vois
jamais faire bon tu peux pas parce que
tu te dis shekels et b5 et b6 je reviens
ouais mais tu as peut-être que peut-être
causé par tv5 à marco 6ème et 5ème en
rock tu peux jouer
ok mais c'est peut-être pas si grave
pour les noirs à fin juin la ligne de
leurs dix à quatre des six cavaliers
detroit fin enfin déjà pourquoi quatre
pieds ce qui est des 3 slim pourrait
l'avantager c'est beaucoup plus logique
de jeu comme ça avec les noirs et tu
fais rock dans un deuxième temps je vois
pas en quoi ta pourquoi ce serait grave
de cette pré à 4 je comprends pas en
fait non non non non tu peu rauque et ou
de fois qu'il veut mais turc rémanents
mais alors dit tu te dis que c'est foutu
pour les noirs mais tu vois c'est pour
ça que c'est injouable avec les noirs
c'est un juge ou un truc normal et tu
comprends même pas pourquoi tu es déjà
foutu de nouveau il fut de quoi un
machin by dédicacé 5 et français 5
débouler des aiguilles est sujette aux
stocks et des quatre pieds et des mains
et tu rentres de partout mais bon quel
moment tu comprends qu'avec les noirs
étaient plus foutu la côte enfin web
annonce nous c'est quasi impossible à
comprendre tu vas prendre pied des
quatre à être votre ferme atc clair en
fait ce qui est des quatre cités
changera plus fous de canwest et
changent pas ce qui va arriver là non
mais c'est sûr que c'est foutu
mais comment tu veux comprendre ça avec
les noirs c'est incompréhensible
ce que rock quand même tu te dis que tu
vas te prendre kg 3
non je pense et de peu d'autres marques
et le b 5e en matant ils te disent ça ça
cavaliers des six pay pouces est calé
g73 g7 c'est pas grave non mais qui va
faire sa femme il te dis que c'est égal
mais qui va jouer ça
comme quoi ça non mais tu peux faire
c'est pas le choix je sais mais là le
truc c'est pas le choix tu dans ton
choix tu vas jamais prendre ce choix la
cci logique de faire ça ton fou g7 tu te
dis qu'il vit un peu ils tapent des
quatre matches à lyon il nous faut se
laisser bouffer c'est s'attaquer droit
non mais c'est imprécis fabriquer des
cinq parcs zoologiques
ok tu menaces rien non mais tu verrais
ça dans des cases c'est maintenant un
peu triste non en fait que tu peux
peut-être ses cavaliers à 3 qui est
bessin grand roque du goût en et en
supprimant l'âge où on apprend à 3 tu le
prends donc à 4 je pense très logique
une série des six logique est ici qu il
ya des trois s'écoute logique du monde
le cavalier est mal placée et tu veux
revenir vers ses ça c'est très normal
que je pense qu'on va avoir cette
position sur l'échiquier mais ciné pause
s'en tire avec des prothèses c'est que
le dieu le protège
ça c'est impossible de s'en sortir de
salles en sommes aujourd'hui
il a été impressionnant jusqu'à
maintenant de d'être encore en vie et
bien en vie c'est déjà incroyable mais
là ça me paraît impossible
quand tu peux pas il ya un moment donné
tu glisses quoi ou alors le mec s'est
entraînés à marcher sur la glace ils ne
disent jamais
ça me paraît tellement impossible et
navara est encore en train de jouer
encore perdu issue c'est vrai en plus
même le truc en noir qui n'est pas
pleutre vos meubles antiques aux débats
il va au combat mais c'est choquant fin
non mais ouais donc le pays bilingue
français logic et b 5 à 4 qui est des
risques et des trolls ça peu
d'agressions que quand on aura je pense
oui mais du gouffre pajot qui produira
quelques énormes que je décroche pas
autour des 8 ou je sais pas quoi le truc
c'est que t'as plus personne qui visent
des 5 avec les moins tu pourras jamais
faire des f-5 tu vas toujours te prend
2,5 à tapas le ca pas le temps de venir
hors jeu mais tu pourras envie de faire
un truc comme ça aille mais laïque y
avaler f4 et attaque la dame à étages et
6 a annoncé markit
non mais là il rentre par tous les
orifices en fait le max non vraiment
signer peau sauf ça c'est s'ingéniant
fait bas où il se trompe à l'émail
zapata pointe on voit que c'est une
partie très dans nos manuels
actuellement je comprenais projet
abandonné l'idée de jouer là grünfeld on
comprend non mais là je pense que j'ai
compris pourquoi pas qui a et b 5
directs ont fait rock en premier forcé
qui jettera ensuite qui est b saint
caprais à 4 ha ouais c'est pas idiot
genre tu ferrand qu'en premier tu
menaces f5 tu provoques kg 3 tu fais qui
avait 5 tu menaces car il est là du coup
tu forces plus ou moins cavalière 5
fitton foot casino est un mieux qui
avait filé le foot casar mais bon ok le
stylo factice
non mais une fois qu avec leurs dix et
comprend aussi mais je viens je n'aurais
même jamais imaginé le truc en fait
perso je sais pas toi fabre entend grand
maître peut il pas ma partie mais en
fait c'est pas un truc que tu veux faire
mais s'ils restent commence à pas trop
aller tu vas te mettre un peu regardé
quand même en désespoir de cause et tu
peux te dire ah bah en fait c'est moins
pire que le reste sera pas vraiment a
dit nullement que tu va regarder ni la
numéro de terre
après sa queue n'est peau et maximy
calcul tellement bien qu'ils sont
capables de voir par le calcul et de
comprendre par le calcul du coup si
jamais scellé rouscoff là si shy'm et
maxime se qualifie pas tu pense qu'on
peut les faires les 500 retweete ou pas
ou c'est infaisable
ça dépend pas de nous deux autres et si
on fait un stream 24 heures pour faire
les 500 recrutements mais après on n'a
pas le temps donc lui faut dormir
il faut compter d'avoir peut-être
navarra faudrait faire un remix et là
les lacs les prépas de navarra je
préfère un ruisseau à la grüne fait
lorsque vous quoi ce serait beau temps
tu cites que des ouvertures que prévu
comme ça bonifie les lacs du connemara
on a oublié de mettre une pub qui en
passent une pub bien comme merci nous le
rappeler le chat les lie du canada et
sera d'énormes remix que ce serait
magnifique
ça va être chaud quand je vais revenir
je vais quand je vais retourner à moscou
du coup on va me retrouvé suicidé de
deux balles dans l'autre pour des
revenus de coin est retenu
a par contre c'est vrai qu'on peut
demander à kiev du rire jaune de nous
aider pour leurs tweets ouais les gens
on retrouve des sens à ce qu'ils font
ouais serait génial qu'on arrive à 4000
retweet la fédé russe en sueur quoi
c'est pour les actionnaires d'avoir un
tueur mini tient pas ce très beau que
même macron en parle
oui il y avait ce problème des retraites
mais qui est passée complètement au
second plan maxime bat sharapova est pas
la wild card
du coup encore plus de grèves en france
oui oui on gueule encore plus quoi parce
que les avions cloués au sol
enfin tout est politique mais je pense
qu'on va le faire le tweet mais je sais
pas si on le fait on peut le faire qu'en
cas de défaite
non mais je pense que le faire avant
pour que les gens se hype
samedi-dimanche faut qu'on prépare un
truc est ce que quelqu'un peut écrire un
truc en anglais bien on en parlera
peut-être c'est sympa mais genre please
at roshan federacion review wild card
policy and and planes match between mvl
end end à l'iccn cocoyes to decide which
player 10 heures vite mort tu as un truc
dans ce style et genre on fait ça en
retweetant hashtag eux on met hashtag
chais sont mes hadfi des est à tu et à
trop chaîne fédération et boum quoi et
après on regarde ce qu'il a comme je
sais pas s'il est sur twitter mais non
mais on fait ça on s'assied et et on
regrette at poutine a de footing et
abstrait à 13h taiwo refait keynews
atout maître yoda aussi pour être sûr
d'avoir du respect dans la réponse quoi
c'est du respect ça mon garçon pour la
wild card c'est du respect non mais je
vois pas pourquoi on le ferait pas en
fait
quel sens pense maintenant que notre 1
face à rennes le faire non plus mais ça
permettra aux jeux seront faits pour
faire ces pas non mais je parle ce qu'on
n'efface pas tout le monde me saoule
avec la wild-card depuis des mois mais
dire oui c'est pas juste qu'il est c'est
pas juste qu'il espère juste qu'ils les
bains du cours spot du coup on va voir
quoi on va voir si si vous avez des
cojones si vous allez retweet si vous si
vous aussi vous en avez une bien
accroché quoi enfin ce que vous vous
opposez à poutine ou pas quoi on verra
on verra on verra on verra tous les
génies du chat à quel point ça reste
dans le chat à quel point ça ça porte ça
les portes quoi twitter que de content
que ça soit de nouveaux abonnés en rouge
de créer un compte juste pour ça un jeu
qui vous allez avoir des problèmes chez
des patients à le faire voir discute
quoi là il ya de l'histoire faut que tu
as écrit un truc
donc à niveau sur fléchi à ses sorties
et b5 tout ça c'est sûr frey ont
augmenté at il lancé une pétition pour
navarro grands titres pour garder parti
un peu tout ça c'est pas bête l'hectare
de créer une pétition sur 100 points
hors gehl a hélas hélas tweet est
peut-être pas idiot on ne sait pas donc
manuel pastilla pas sonné pour bâle
facile du tout
l'armée n'est pas va perdre de façon
fort on va même pas avoir besoin de
faire le tweet ce que maxime va se
qualifier en fait ça va ça va bien se
passer est inquiète pas ça bien se
passer et fecit b5 mieux faire cailler
des six équipes évolution mais c'est le
plus humain de toute façon femme est
tuée à skis et prend à 3 de toute façon
fait un tué et induit quand même à
quatre horloges équipe après tu peux
s'il ya pas qu'à te faire payer ces
quatre c'est que ça doit pas regarder
battu défend à 3 c'est logique serait
logique aussi tout est tellement logique
dans ce jeu
ouais c'est logique d'après leurs dires
une bonne chose au québec schiste
redisons mais si ça ouais mais c'est
logique souhaité changer une qui après
tout est logique c'est en toute logique
mais bon enfin delajoux qui arrivent ici
c'est chez moi j'aurais plutôt pensé
qu'ils étaient six personnes pour
reclasser ce truc là
mais l'annoncé d'un couple non marié des
changes du coup il fait qu'il y ait
trois pièces non ils n'ont peut-être pas
lire et s'éprend des cadres mais tu
défends de 4 t'arrive
ouais mais bon à 4 tu prépares un peu
p5q chasse le cavalier je sais pas si
j'ai l'impression qu'elle me fait
beaucoup de choses avec ce coup
donc
donc donc manuel dirigerait dam des
trois dames des trois idiots m mais bon
tu as mené 3 tu prends un peu la casse
du canal quand même qu'ils voulaient
aller verser 5 mai peyo alors non mais
possible et aussi tour des huit têtes un
jouet du caïeu cinq femmes ont bien
besoin
mais bon passons outre le bruit c'est de
faire à quatre marchands j'aurais fait
soit 4 5 et 6 et 4 dames 10 mois je
pense pas que j'aurais fait mais à
quatre pour faire qu'il y ait trop ce
que nous sommes et revenir vers ses
seins qu'on a vu depuis tout à l'heure
que la casse ces cinq elle est vraiment
belle
gilles rolland qui prendrait puisse être
partie avance moi je suis confiant bon
va-t-on être parti en fanfare mais c'est
vrai que là c'est moins simple moi je
suis enfin toujours un jeu reste
confiant les mecs on en voit on envoie
des good vibes aujourd'hui on fait on
fait de la goutte fight là on ne sait
pas pour le moment ça va on est bien on
va pas on va pas faire la mauvaise
énergie là après on va faire les chats
noirs non non non on reste positif là
tout le monde allez les mecs un peu un
peu de positif à bien des gens un petit
peu plus positif que ça dans le chat
vous allez c'est vous qui allez nous
faire perdre là je vais être de notre
faute
j'étais obligé de battre non mais si ça
continue est négatif je vais masse ban
fab à partir les balles vont partir les
gens négatifs ça va partir a les seins
on est on est tous heureux on est tous
la vie est belle voilà tu vois il nous
écrit wesh wesh ça c'est beau mais le
club ouais voilà vous mettez y soit
nightclub positivité positive attitude
non non ça va ça va ça
il a quand même beaucoup de messages
dans le chat en train de regarder avec
les seconds est touché et imagine le
nombre de messages à la seconde 1 qui
assure ce chat c'est sait on se croirait
on se croirait sur on se croirait
sur une émission twitch normal en fait
ça t'as pas l'impression que tu regardes
les échecs quand tu regardes ce chat tu
dis je regarde un truc normal non parce
que des fois quand je regarde des échecs
y a personne tu vois je comprends
qu'est-ce qui se passe ouais ya beaucoup
de monde
enfin j'veux pas ce qu'ils font ils ont
que ça à faire un mercredi après midi
regarder des échecs on sait pas quoi la
france va mal à moi je te lis femmes
n'ont ni personne d'autre
il ya des grèves vous que ouais c'est
peut-être ça aussi son stock et toi ton
chat très calme moi j'ai du bol parce
que vendredi ça joue pas et vendredi on
m'annonce une alerte rouge météo donc
l'alerté rouge météo
tu as tiens il a fait attends attends
femmes excuses des excuses fabre retour
au direct désolé à quatre qui avaient
des systèmes pos kg 3 f 5 tempo et la
fête qui j'ai trop du caïd des trois ans
fatwa qui est très logique faillir tout
est logique mais là l'ordi avantage voir
maintenant voilà je commence à faire à
mes affaires dans mon froc
non c'est toi qui est plus positif non
je suis positif je suis dans mon froc en
étant positif on a quand même le droit
en france aujourd'hui en 2020 de d'avoir
des problèmes gastriques et d'être
d'avoir la positive attitude quand même
j'aime et j'ai mis les couches bleed
stream donc je suis tranquille
aujourd'hui
donc quel point f5 et pro f 5 e prend un
f5 boîte de production photo juste un
truc on peut pas reprendre déjà déjà il
veut mettre sa dame imaginant des cinq
sets plus logique de le guen aidé à me 4
oui bon ça va reste revient avec les
blancs faut arrêter non je leur dis tout
dit popp donne des 5e dom madoff mais
qui joue damas depuis d'autres personnes
et surtout rhin ont été refaits dam des
cinq équipes qui revient et sur d'homme
de dieu que tu te dis juste que c'est
déjà un accomplissement de rami la tour
en 1 au gascon seulement ça c'est
logique si tu voir g à deux tours 1
c'est sûr tu as affaire damade
d'ordinateurs est ce que pour le coup ce
genre de koné et dames f7 toujours nommé
america iii et fuite oui mais ça
pourquoi souffrir a accueilli ses quatre
filles peut dire que ça ça va non
à
à voir ici on fait pions prend dire
mesdames des 5 es là tu saches qu'on
prend ce nom mais il va pas faire foirer
t il va pas faire d'amadou le mec il aux
yeux non mais qui fait sa direction
c'était un peu d'ouvrir 24 dames des
cinq d'avocats de 60 est obligé de faire
mon devoir a tu dis d'arcade
ah ouais ça tu es obligé de voir nos
bouquets pose la question qui tue et
surtout pas prendre ce que ça tu
abandonnes direct une marée de pions ça
tu regardes ça tu regarde même pas une
seconde non tu peux regarder roi des
huit ici man mais ok 6 4 ouais bon tu
peut qu'aimer tours 8
cavani hamsik royal st
bon c'est pas forbes et tu veux faire
roi 17 aux arrêts mercredi 7 sur un
caillou 5
non mesdames à deux c'est dur de séduire
l'intérieur se traduit il ne va pas
trouver
c'est un peu la pls dans le camp
français la fable la positive attitude
l'aller où c'est un peu c'est un peu là
c'est un peu la lose lose attitude l'afo
faut qu'on reprenne faut qu'on prenne la
positive attitude là les mecs je vous
sens je vous sens un peu mort là non
nous propose qu'ils avaient h5 chat
menace le fou g7
tu joues qua non le chat room aux
cavaliers 5
c'est logique qu'ils aient pas m bon
apparemment d'après leur dire ok bien
présent
l'homme se défend thon rouge et sèche
des pièces sur ecolo neuf fois est ce
que j'étais en train de me dire qu'ils
les trucs michael provocateur france 4
et france 4 qui ressemblait à ce café
maximilian pour soi même moi j'entends
km cg temps d'en calculer ça en fait
j'en reçois même ça ça peut faire un fou
j'ai alors dit me calmer price watch toi
il ferait froid ça j'avais vu mais
heureusement j'avais pas vu en fait
j'avais vu roigé trois rois g23 g12
départ des autres les rois ou deux
peut-être aussi miroir d'un gc ca de
coups que j'ai pas regardé à maintenant
c'est de bons coups sûrs oui mais pas
étonnant je suis bien nul comme prévu
j'aime pas le scénario là
c'est quoi encore est un film français
là c'est un film d'auteur français la
comédie bien donc à qui il a loupé damas
deux ouais j'ai ça mais ce qu'ils
veulent voir mais est ce que dit à
maxime la vue ou pas mais d'un tout ce
qui m'inquiète c'est que ni coiffée f5
tempo quand même comme s'il avait vu
quelque chose parce que je veux dire
c'est pas tempo si t'as rien vu un
remède à la 2 sur ces beaux quoi parce
que tu t'empêches un pelé qui avait de
bouger des changes d'hommes ont battu
souffle dans le final et après ce qui
est visible aussi avec damas deux
secteurs sur la même rangée que le roi
ça ne souvent envie ça non mais c'est
vrai que si tu forces turin pour
repartir en dessin abstrait aller dans
l'autre étudiant c'est une version
tellement améliorée donc c'est pas c'est
invisible
ouais non mais en plus soit il a
vraiment joué vite assez souvent ainsi
que tu as quand même enfin tu avait tout
prévu quelque chose avec c'était ali
numéro un et que
tu rends dans un truc quel jeu qu'elle
fut pensée la banque libye dont ses
potes tempo c'est quand tu joues
directement tu vas t'on der sar jours de
la petite pendule sur le côté etc la
claque il appuie et walasiak rac youku
voix lors il n'y a pas à qualifier
travaille justement à cause de ça parce
que le voile sur cavale et f5 qui avec
5.5 spar est génial pour les blancs
parce que sur internet on l'a vu il va y
avoir des dames quatre échecs et on va
on va arriver avec moi déboule avec le
cavalier verser 5 et sur dame dessin qui
est le coup super logique de
centralisation de l'adami adam quatre
échecs et le truc c'est que sur dame
prend 2,4 et 3,4
on est une majorité centrale on va faire
cinq à six deux prochains coups et ça a
l'air d'être très bien mais le truc
c'est que l'ordi propose de commencer
par damas deux pour quelque part dévier
la tour parce que la dame est très bien
placé et revenir par la suite en d5 et
sur dame e4 maintenant fait roi des 8 et
toute la différence c'est que le tempo
que tu as perdu ce affecter un peu des
quatre sous pression ça fait que ça
arrive plus vite côté noir et ça change
à la colonne de détail important les
vins comme ça genre par exemple balata
envie de faire tour à ses seins et du
coup il a le temps de faire tour c8 et
de s'organiser et bankinter ifat manque
un tempo et autre chose aussi importante
vraiment c'est sur damas de damas quatre
échecs au but struyf cette étude est le
fait qu il défend la case ya pas de tour
un excès de me trouver deux ou trois
permanents pour défendre donc les
vallées en plus mes deux séances ont
rejoint chelsea en huitièmes au choix
mais c'est hyper hyper hyper dur de voir
ça avance surtout dans une partie à
autant d'enjeux fab c'est assez
impressionnant ce qui fait l'époque en
milieu de jeu je trouve
après ont pour source et la fin
d'avant-midi meilleurs atours 8 qui
arrivera avec tempo la dame noire
reviendra vers des 5 et ses morts ses
traits à qui l'accès très haut blanc
heureusement sinon y'aurait f4 entre
chaque thème est ce que voient les
pousse à abuser c'est très très bien
joué j'ai bien joué c'est un peu ce que
fait maxime d'habitude ce qui est en
train de vivre peut-être faut rentrer
dans cette finale un peu
est ce que faire d'autre mon lit là ça
le faisait on embauche alpha 0 serait
pas en trois sets par aller à la
rochelle 9 0 en fait tu peux que la voie
romaine quartz heures de google va
falloir standard dit comme ça je tape à
disposition donc non donc oui c'est
lille à zéro c'est la version gratuite
mitidja très fort sur kf5 petit rock
mais on comprend le roi s'est mis à
l'abri à la colonne f on est dans le dur
fab mais bon en cas de défaite ce serait
pas le scénario le plus détestable parce
que maxime il aurait pas raté sa chance
pas chez soi partout
j'aurais plus d'impressions là j'aurais
pas l'impression qu'il a donné le match
quoi j'ai l'impression juste que l'autre
te fais une partie d'extraterrestres à
ce moment-là du tournoi et sa fin tut
tut alençon d'être tombé sur plus fort
que toi je prends f5 jouais pas du
cavalier oui madame des cinq ça fait mal
on donne des 5 s'avère logique autre
conception d'un mot de passe est atone
mon lit je vous aime bien mais bon ok
d'amd 5 je trouve plus beaucoup beaucoup
logisco ya pas d'aveu 400 me non mais
pourquoi tu t'en beta là tu vas faire ça
et peut-être à peut-être petit rock
après ça reste compliqué hein
entouraient tour est tout est faisable
mais là je pense que l'epo a vraiment
égaliser fab peut-être l'idée de mac /
d'amd 500 cavaliers h5 way avec l'idée
sur cavaliers prendre la route dames 100
kg 7
ouais mais y'a pire est toujours non mes
amis rock toujours qu'il est pouvoir et
sur la colonne est fait maintenant 22 il
possible non non et paula je pense que
s'il fait dam des cinq fables il ya même
plus davantage pratique pour les blancs
n'ont encore des sports qui je voue
thème pour des conneries bien sûr bien
sûr ça reste très compliqué mais juge
veut dire que le bénéfice de l'ouverture
se sera dissipée même quand il ya un
avantage voire même ont peut-être
d'après leur dîme la pression reste
tellement chaotique que hal caché qui
n'est pas dans le top 10 mondial à deux
places à rennes venons il faut croiser
les doigts qui le blender c'est tout
ouais c'est vrai que max linder s'est
fait dépasser du coup au classement
mondial par aronian emma mais oui mais
bon non mais c'est anecdotique
c'est dingue down
non dans l'absolu non mais là récemment
ouais mais il avait été enfin il perd
des points à tous les tournois après
n'est pas il pourra aussi gaffé en
finale c'est tout le temps belga par
robin ça existe tellement la partie
miroir d'hier sauf que l'epo a pas raté
la rupture avec avec f5 équivalente à
ces cinq pour maxi mais je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que dit robin là c'est
un peu ça robin side qui fait un
commentaire j'ai envie dit on sait
pourquoi il à l'épée un commentaire très
pertinent dans le chat c'est vrai que
c'est un peu le miroir mais je tuais
mais c'est pour ça que c'est vrai que
siné paul a gagné tout il aura vraiment
mérité les flancs seront ce qu'ils
demandent menace pour voir des joueurs
et leur tête tu peux les sur le youtube
de world check
alors tu veux à labatut coupe le son et
tu nous écoutes dam dam des cinq
mutuelles inverse
tu ne regardes et tu m'as secoué le
centre commercial n'est venu à l'automne
comme c'est bien aussi se poser si bas
si j en apprends le bad guy berger je
penche peut être numéro un mondial a
carrément une rayettes bien mais ne va
pas regarder notre tête non ils sont
beaucoup trop moche je préfère aller
voir quand même les vrais joueurs le
chignon infâme un prono pour ce soir
mais à quoi sert un choix qui anime
saint-aimé le tas ou du classique
christie co tu prennes barça real ce
soir je pense qu'ils parlent de nîmes
santé que tu va regarder à la place du
classique ou quoi non mais en fait chaud
toile fait de l'animation 17 faut au
foot plus fins faut un truc canal
spécial au fait tu n'as pas ton bar à
paris la tombe arts de chine
enfin j'ai pas traverser la ville à pied
pour avoir un hymne sainti bats toi tes
supporters de sainté souhaitait pas
supporter des fans à fond mais moi je
connais des stéphanois qui l'aurait fait
bien non
rien voilà en https tacle dangereux cgt
ni comme un semi tacle ah non j'ai
répondu tu étais là bas ils te disent
jérémie janot la magie le fonds vert
supporters de sainté voilà alors c'est
bien bien vu fab
j'ai essayé de te prendre le ballon
était intervenu rageur avec un tacle à
un tacle bien bien placé un tacle dit
mais qu'est ce qu est le coût pour le
clasico je sais pas moi j'ai plutôt pro
barça en général après je suis peu afin
servira que je suis parce qu'ils sont
supporters du barça quoi c'est juste
certainement là ils sont contents dans
le chat et c'est un beau tacle de ta
part il reste 58 1 et postiac nippon fut
si je vous dit non mais ici sortait de
sa mère partie de l'année aujourd'hui
oui mais il est capable de faire des
grosses game on se rappelle aux grandes
chaînes sur balles à cinéphiles car
justement que tu commenté il avait super
bien commencé avant de faire
complètement n'importe quoi il est
capable du meilleur comme du pire
l'annoncé de même il est instable mais
en fait oui il battait pas de 1775 ont
étendu le thé sur wii je n'ai même pas
de 1800 pense que le chat
enfin 2800 et lommois ya une base du
chat un voeu mais du coup l'un des
comiques après la phase de fabrice ils
demandent comment je paye la zéro et le
télécharger il faut lire des tutoriels
assez on peut pas expliquer sa sueur sur
le tchad sur le c'est trop compliqué
magnien d'être bien aiguillé il ya
mathieu qui m'a aussi envoyé des biens
des trucs avec deux lettres je peux
arriver
donc tu dois pouvoir y arriver je suis
pas non plus un informaticien hors pair
mais c'est difficile
en gros faut que tu regardes bien ce que
c'est ta carte graphique tu télécharges
le bon truc en fonction
et c'était après ça va pas faisable mais
tu peux pas juste télécharger facilement
gagné 1 cliquable où je coince un peu
plus oublier que ça te donne des liens
de chasse base etc
difficile enfin aujourd'hui je m'étends
pas partie de ma part a vite fait pour
voir qu'à rallier ses carreaux il va
rentrer la finale ce que tu disais mais
mérite la bonne mais tu perds ferment à
4 nuls ok je vais peut-être jouer comme
ça mais tu joues pour l'augmentation ne
peut pas tenu bah oui non mais assez tu
fais nul dans les banques a atteint
depuis qu'elle tue peu embrouillée
dessins que toi tu mais même cette
embrouille du père des cinq et b4
vraiment à plus de pions que amy surtout
qu'on puisse le faire qu'elle prend
prise prise prise et on saisit d'un
gaullisme peut-être aussi faire juste
chirac nique et des singes et les 5 et
tours 8 qui arrivait au lasso plus que
mise à part gaffe de nespouls je pense
est finie la balade valérie bordé oui
état du tout obligé de fermer le prince
rouge et digne anne on perd ce n'est pas
obligé mais juste une lutte pendule
normalement bah ouais et gagner gagner
ok tu de prier pour la gaffe rue bâillon
nous dit positif attitude la femme on
est parti de la positive attitude la
sapa ça va pas du tout là bravo à
blender ou qui nous qui nous rappelle un
peu à l'ordre brian minto c'est quand
même un gaffeur professionnels fab face
à la qualification il a quand même
glissé non pas l'église quoi à l'église
dont il se bat aujourd'hui son final
ouais c'est vrai quoi on va être
positive attitude les mecs là encore
navarra qui qui peut nous sauver la mise
non sérieux ils effraient navarra moi je
moi je le sens si navarra va en finale
sérieuse semble n'avoir à favori non non
il fait un gros tournoi david il est
très bien préparée dans les ouvertures
solide en milieu de jeu fort en
stratégie ça va il n'y a pas de souci
c'est réussi navarra y passe c'est notre
meilleure chance on a vraiment beaucoup
de chance fable que ce soit lui qui en
finale silva on est vraiment très
chanceux on n'aurait pas aimé un quart
yakine voix ou un wesley so heureux il
l'a eue sur sa route à son maître au
final même ce serait tellement beau
coxon devra le sauveur ultime
ce serait magnifique navarre à notre
nouvelle héroïque est ce que tu es fort
non mais ce serait le délire de la
chaîne poussé à son paroxysme dans la
boucle serait bouclée c'est ça en fait
c'est ce serait peut-être même le
meilleur fin au conflit pour lui qu'ils
y arrivent ils à l'amphidice vous compte
n'est pas parce que ça me paraît
impossible mais honnêtement pour nous ce
serait genre le meilleur scénario
possible quoi on est en plein de blaye
et aux banques a franchement no fake
j'ai quasiment je sais pas comment
trouver mais j'aurais bien acheté un
drapeau de la république tchèque au
montech le drapeau et tout quoi tqui
héros navarre à quoi bon aller changer
une fois ces quatre bons joueurs pendant
que l'on ne fait pas de me prendre
oui c'est sûr
dudu qu'il navarra qui le qualifie parce
que nés peau connaissait pas l'ouverture
sur la carreau cannes ce serait magique
au niveau qui gagnent avec les noirs
dans une quarantaine ce sera
extraordinaire nationale j'étais rendu
malade et en navarre a qui gagnent
attends attends de gracier unités contre
une toile de 1 où sa dame prend des gaz
dans ce cas qui avait si sûr ça reste
c'est ce qu'on disait il a vu cavaliers
prend m6 c'est ce qu'on disait à mathieu
sa tour eiffe 51.7 c'est l'idée c'est
sur des dessins on va voir
et voilà dans ce sens exact et je vais
prendre ce pion à 4 banon par les chutes
de rock du coup pour tout éviter mètres
la tour ans je préparais tour des huit
fait à même pas tout au moins qui est
normalement ben on est à huit à égalité
matérielle meilleure structure d'options
ah oui dans ta tout est clair non mais
une maxime aurait les noirs on serait
très heureux d où il va presser va
peut-être la gagne with high tour e 5
pts 6v 5d prend 1,5
du coup c'est encore plus inquiétant qui
est deux idées pour les blancs c'est à
dire que ça les fait tourner le problème
c'est que si tu fais tour ces cinq
niveaux il va tout de suite comprendre
qu'il prend 1,4 et une idée bah tu fais
pas tour à cinq mètres ton plus en prise
sur tempo n'est due qu'au rock nom du
coureur et si on peut trouver un truc
sur
est-ce que tu comprends tout à fait mais
pas de négativité pardon oui il ne va
rien comprendre
évidemment il va faire tes prend à 4
tours 5 bon allez on y croit les mecs on
est dedans
allez on est dans le game
fab allez allez allez il a le temps
c'est simple ouais maxi maxime allez
allez allez allez maxi ça peut ça peut
marcher ça peut marcher femmes on peut y
aller on peut y aller oui il arrête de
réfléchir et joue sexy voudrais pas il
peut faire qui les prend 1,4 maintenant
aux alentours ces 5 tu comprends qu'ils
le gagnent misère à la tête par yahia
pas de faire du rock pour ce tour 5 fait
du tord 8 tu fais rien parce que tous
les regards et chatou charest ait eu
s'en fout en fait malgré ça intéressant
c'est intéressant il trouve encore de la
ressource match aller max ouais ouais
c'est un accueil pour un cadre du coup
faut pas faire pour les noirs si fait
qu'elle ait des cinq sa hausse à vous
qui se regardait 5 je pense même pas je
pense aussi mais ça donne quoi avec tout
droit 17 ou un truc comme ça concept
mieux ou 4 km h un partout quéven s'est
pas fait mais bon on peut aussi un truc
maroc serrant le cou le plus logique par
excellence je pense bref c'est aussi
peut-être qu'ils se regardent même état
peut-être dès 2005 pour ça c'est vrai
rock c'est vraiment ultra logique et
quelle qualité des soins
bon allez on y croit kevin est ce qu
elle vibre vraiment pour cette qualif
bah oui hein c'est son objectif
principal la saison on nous écrit
boulette de dépôt il a fait quoi qu'il
arrive j'ai pas envie boulette de dépôt
dans le tchat
il a peut-être la sphère sa boulette cbl
fois mais là actuellement il l'a pas
fait
ah oui ce fake alors on nous demande ce
qu'attend pourquoi acheter catalan
pourquoi qu'avec les points à 4 tours 5
un buzz je prends 1 500 prend 1,5 et il
avance que quatre qui arrivait à quai et
des six qui a fuit 6 1 6 7 6 puis on
passe est lié s'était pas gagnant mais
ça joue sur quel
la partie a glissé on regardera pape
dans le résumé je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs moments où sap
ils étaient quatre bigote qui fait de la
casse et 4 et la fée rock de punk mais
peut-être b4 l'arrêt ça a laissé damas
six dames c4 est peut-être mieux
commencer par cavalier feux de on verra
dans le résumé femme c'était compliqué
peut pas dire ça vraiment glissé sur un
coup direct pharma je pense à surtout
glissé sur le fait que n'ai pas joué une
partie de malades
personnellement pour l'instant il fait
pas de conneries que non mais ça me fait
penser il s'est quand à des gros
avantages contraint stockfisch pareil
accessit
en fait tu arrêtes tu vas pas la gagne
pas c'est pareil en fait c'est plutôt
fin pour moi c'est plutôt dépôts qui
sort une partie des extraterrestres
aujourd'hui j'ai pas femmes comment tu
le donnes tu le sens oui pour l'instant
pour l'instant je dors à 5 est
maintenant qu'il ya des cinq très
logique il va faire b5 et tours 8 je
mets la pression là tu mets la pression
la cavalcade probablement et bien j'ai
quatre des cinq il ya tout qui arrive la
femme ouais juste pour preuve cinq noms
mais ça avec les noirs tu es super
confiant d'en racheter perdu un jeu là
je l'aï vu j'étais parti regarde un peu
la tête des joueurs ouais et alors on
fait visiter sur navarro oui il peut
faire qui a aidé cette aussi brackin pas
si mauvais mais qui est des s'inscrivent
logiquement cédé 5 c'est le coup de plus
logique c'est normal données en dessin
comme si tu veux je pense que s'ils
meurent pas c'était là il donnera un
gros conseil à maxime c'est gagner une
demi finale kévin de repenser à ton
prono initial maxine n'arrache pas la
qualification lui-même mais il l'a quand
même à la fin ouais c'est vrai que c'est
ce que j'avais dit maxime craquer son
adversaire à ses adversaires directs
craque aussi vrai que pour le moment je
serai dans les coûts de mon prono de
base
c'est pas faux
temps ça ça bouge du côté de navarra a
fait une finale manuellement sahraouis
de 30 noms mais il sait les faire il a
déjà tenu une contre-visite yougov au
dernier grand prix comme ça avec tournoi
mais en fait vigueur qu'on pourrait
absolument pas ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
une un truc pour fou il a été la
terrière ont fait navarrenx perdre une
finale de toi capture de moi mais juste
là bien tenu mais j'ai dû courir moi ça
changerait toutes les interviews
cohabiter au fil des finances de presse
crise et puis j'ai complètement égal et
puis david a tout fait pour essayer de
perdre mais c'était quand même nul il ne
leur a dit non en fait il a déjà joué
une finale comme ça il savait que ça
allait fermer
donc il est entré dans les deux visions
différentes de trucs je repasse une
petite page de pub fabre avant voir si
l'effet qu'a été sa coupe à petit pas de
plus les mecs huit minutes bieli tu
regardes une pub ben c'est bien ça fait
souffler d'ailleurs une question la pub
et que surtout elle va sur youtube ce
michael sur tric ce n'est pas
malheureusement il est question mis sur
youtube
acer qui en fait en organique sans la
première page mais peut-être 2500 là
c'est énorme quand y penser et non c'est
vraiment énorme
merci les mecs sains du coup de suivre
puisque je ne savais pas mais juge que
ce sont pour les brunchs assez sur le
passage au 20h et ce comme hockey
d'antan mon nez genre 900 895 un poil
plus ça quand j'étais là il ya trois
minutes mais ok quand même pas mal quoi
demis 9 500 joueurs ici oui mais à
peut-être 1200 gars qui sont là grâce à
la première page on cuit ça fait à peu
près ça se fait à peu près de 1500
personnes en organique c'est énorme
vraiment
c'est bien c'est beau il est joué
qu'edison ouais ça mais c'est beau c'est
pourquoi la hype des échecs mais
j'imagine avant quand a été émis l'on
sait que c'est extraordinaire on avait
fait dans l'armageddon aronian mach 1
1506 5 rouillac en suivant des 2500 wall
c'est bien en mains d'une seule oui mais
j'ai retourné sa deuxième crise et même
chose comme ils sont en baisse du nombre
de gens prennent de trop de coups
maintenant des options et prend des gars
devront better bewitched horgan b sont
les pires jamais en fait juste et
ambitieux mais ce cri des trois échecs
lors du transfert des 5 et d 3 j'ai
froid j'ai deux qui essaient 5 prise sur
moi même pas la variante on se prend des
essais prend des fois fait très fort ça
tombe bien tu fais toujours poussé
saint-cloud b6 onctueux même bannière
des champions b donc ok nul signé la
mairie fixe fabien us un jeu bien
qu'hors tanks et des sponsors deans mais
ok c'est juste pour le coup de jeune et
beau nom mais enfin est dommage de bach
plus fructifier parce que belle position
après l'ouverture
je les marches non mais je suis sûr se
signer mais j'ai calmé les vergers nancy
y parle ici ni
[Musique]
saab en moi bah c'est enfin c'est le
match est abandonnée et du coup faut
prier pour la défaite de nespouls finale
maintenant voilà bon côtière alors là on
ya cru en plus aujourd'hui on ya cru
parce que parce que parce que bamako une
belle position il a tenté son truc
je pense que l'ouverture c'était juste
super bien pour lui parler d'ordi
confirme tout le monde on était super
chaud mais là prennent du poids très
bien défendu ils étaient bons il était
très bon dans le jeu voit que faire
juste le féliciter gervais munger envie
de dire en fait les gens effectif
je sais pas j'ai pas quoi dire battez du
sud mais il nous reste une once de la
chance lorsque la chance de demain enfin
demain d'autres pour la finale que
peut-être navarin devra s'imposer
mondement regardera pas les départage
dire non et on se retrouve pour la
finale du coup à partir de
samedi dimanche lundi je crois qu'un
jour de repos vendre tu peux vérifier
pour pour la chaîne y aurait un faux nom
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya un jour de repos
le temps ma fille n'avait soi que l'on
finit pas un dimanche ici on finirait
lundi au quai très logique
je comprends pas en fait que dans la
partie
la partie
[Musique]
je comprends pas je comprends pas après
l'ouverture une heure après on pensait
que seraient gagnées en une heure du
matin
non je comprends pas je comprends très
bien parce qu en fait mais oui c'est le
genre de partie que max rappuyer comme
ça mais en fait peut-être que hilda pas
partie non plus m il a joué plutôt
logique
pas trop mal mais il n'a pas été précis
au moins été mieux il n'y a pas joué
assez précis c'est ce que tu disais
c'est le milan ac bordeaux quoi s'est
retiré dans notre sens dans cette partie
si tu n 2 0 et tu prend trois buts en 30
minutes quoi genre tu mènes 2-0 à la 60e
et en fait à 80e et ga 3 2 quoi ça
arrive des fois voilà et pourquoi on
parle pas d'origine on ont envahi peut
très bien patiné potion final six
qualifiés c'est juste une odeur navarra
et que ça sera un beau truc mais
d'ailleurs pour le coup oui reste plutôt
fabriquons navarra d'ailleurs dans leur
demi-finale ils vont sûrement faire nul
et se jouant en départage demain et donc
voilà meiway la tendance est sûrement se
fout des deux ratés en fait sous des
deux jeux pour ces carnages toutes les
rentes qu'on voyait c'était à pic même
là la partie est du repas ben quoi c'est
qu'en fait un match qui devait
normalement ils doivent plus 30 minutes
à la fin il avait comme une fusée non
mais à la fin je souhaitais juste mal
avec les blancs
tu te bats pour faire nul au mieux mais
tu peux plus me kg 3 photo cl oui il est
plusieurs
enfin c'est ce qu'il appelle des travaux
ci l'a pas fait
rien de super catastrophique mais en
fait il a fondu petit à petit son
avantage il n'a pas fait un coup pourri
mais pas très bien pas très bien pas
très bien pop et l'ipo toujours le mieux
possible les jeux comme à l'ordinaire
ont certes l'effet ouverture cata mais
après il avait comme un ordi et la venue
voilà juste ça quoi non mais c'est vrai
que la maxime pour moi il n'a pas craqué
mentalement et pour moi la licra contre
plus fort que lui je comprends pas
toutes lettres tout au long de l'année
il est au dessus il est au dessus il au
dessus alors soit les autres c'est
s'aider cdd peter poté pas assez des
fusées et en fait le jour j y viennent
encore plus fort c'est jusqu'au mise et
valence
c'est la théorie de vlad aussi c'est
qu'en fait les les grands compétiteurs
le jour le jour j ils sont encore tu
vois qu'il en rajoute encore une couche
c'est un peu comme quand tu vois une
finale de grand chelem nadal djoko c'est
plus forte si tu les vois jouer en demie
d'un atp 500 quoi mais je comprends pas
à l'epo cera pas l'air d'être une fusée
quoi [ __ ] son nez profond birkin
safina s'est pas fait tu peux avoir la
décompression te dire ok c'est j'ai
battu élevé je suis quasiment candidat
joue pas je joue pas trop un mec trop
bon final tu dois trop beau tu te
planter là après moi je suis un peu avec
mathieu ce matin il est la malchance et
qui sait qu'au pire il garde oui non
mais il n'a pas la pression d'eau mais
bon on va c'est quand même con d'arriver
là et de perdre affichée contre patented
pression quand même
wen en maxime qui a tout donné et tout
donner tout donné et tout donner tout
donner tout donné
il a fait ce qu'ils pouvaient quoi mais
s'il ya plus 20 la partie d'hier n'était
pas terrible aujourd'hui bon choix
d'ouverture pour le coup on était malin
très malin pour l'ouverture et après
c'est dans le jeu que ça s'est moins
bien passé quoi
voilà du coup et si tu vois si c'était
la première fois que ça arrive tu es pas
autant abattu voilà c'est le scénario
qui se répète c'est cinquième fois ce
fut un jour sans fin quand devenu pour
le jour de la marmotte jeu
cette demi finale toujours toujours
toujours et puis c'est encore lui ce
n'est peut-être moins cruel que
contreras déjà ou quoi finalement
aujourd'hui parce que quand même c'est
enfin on l'a déjà dit on va le répéter
quand même nepomniachi sort une partie
majuscule 1 1 il sort quand même une
partie de mal à vraiment infâme
non mais il a bien joué il ya peu
fédéralisation d'ouverture pub choix
incompréhensibles mais à partir de là il
a serré les boulons laisser le jeu à
fond et voilà
mais on le sait il est capable de filer
des pièces en un il est capable de jouer
des parties comme ça c'est une épaule je
le répète mais on l'avait vu à l'asim
que phil cap il avait fait ça et avait
fait des parties de fou après contre
allende se donne une pièce en un an fin
c'est ça en fait n'est pas bon après la
question c'est pourquoi est ce que dans
ces moments là on se retrouve avec le
grand dépôt et pourquoi dans ce moment
là on se retrouve et que le petit mvl
quoi c'est un plus à la question je
pense profonde à se poser ouais mais ça
ne peut pas répondre pas nous n'en
savons pas nous on constate un peu de
loin mais non mais c'est la question à
se poser est banale et réponses enfin
non non c max qui peut éventuellement
changer des trucs autour de lui sa
cellule corpore des gens sains sa sicile
envie de le faire
six ans qu'il faut le faire ou des
choses comme ça niveau préparer au top
alors on peut pas dire que soit la prépa
dans l'ouverture qui est joué il a quand
même une super position avec l'ouverture
après ces six faillites il est crevé
après non mais c'est sûr qu'avoir joué
londres avons sept reports alors tu peux
revoir justement les gens quitteront ton
planning pour voir tes choix de tournois
t'es pas obligé de faire plein de trucs
ça c'est sûr mais c'est vrai qu'après il
a bon aujourd'hui s'est battu
aujourd'hui on va pas l'accabler non
plus et dire que c'est de la merde quoi
ça il y 4 ème mondial a fait rêver et
ils sont pas finies enfin là avant c'est
mal barré mais c'est pas fini pour aller
aux candidats sachant que le nippon par
craquer au final où je ne sais pas quoi
mais ouais bon ok juste c'est décevant
parce que c'est chaque fois un peu
pareil et ça il faudrait arriver à
rompre ce cercle vicieux
ou bien parce qu'il ya un truc qui
semble je tente un schéma qui se répète
c'est sûr en base il ya deux ans n'est
pas d'aller jouer le grand show sur le
problème mais c'était avec liv et la
sortie du livre et plateaux télé ma
chambre est peut-être l'énergie pas d'y
penser la simple et très différemment
là on dit ah ouais mais s'est qualifié à
londres mais à chaque fois y'a un truc
en fait on a l'impression qu'il arrive
pas dans l'est dans les conditions
optimales après c'est difficile de juger
de l'extérieur
oui moi je sais pas je suis pas dedans
rien de choquant après tu peux aussi
juste ce que je suis tombé sur plus fort
soit le jour j vous juste pas de chance
mais j'y crois pas que 15 fois il se
souvient avec sont au top et toi non
il ya des raisons une des raisons mais
tu vois nous à titre personnel quand il
a été qualifié pour le grand duché
sourds tous les deux on s'est parlé on
n'était pas très content qu'il y ait un
mot sur ce que vous votez pas une bonne
chose
financièrement c'est bien mais mais qui
en fait si ça va se venger sur sa marge
en parler un peu avec favre avec femmes
avec vlad c'est après cette
qualification contre magnus mais lisez
en fait kiffer était heureux pour maxime
et tout ce qu'on a vécu le match à fond
et tu en étais dans l'euphorie mais il
visait en fait c'est pas si sûr que ce
soit si bien par rapport au grand prix
puisque du tout contre udine il va être
en finale face à ces noms mais le
problème c'est pas
c'est qu'en plus même si part des
grandes banques us et est resté bon je
me suis retrouvée mais peut-être aussi
rapide peut être que match pour fringe
fait deux nuls rapide en 30 me contre
aronian et puis tu joues un jour de
rapides à larache mais savait qu'on
allait en finale tu te contredis hng
c'était des grosses parties en fuite il
ya dû se battre à fond la fine avec les
quatre d'amway langue anglaise les
machins ouais ouais c'est vrai qu'il
arrivait un petit peu grillé et puis en
plus sûre sur ce cycle des grands prix
et tout ça on peut dire qu'il est quand
même de la réussite au tirage au sort
avec les joueurs qui l'affronté affronté
quand même trois fois topalov en trois
grands prix kennington clairement le
joueur le plus faible du tableau c'est
quand même un peu on peut pas dire que
côté entre guillemets chance réussit à
l'été contre lui bon sens mais bon ok la
dernière chance et tu pries pour un
dépôt qui perd la finale mais déjà c'est
pas beau de porto reste entre les mains
s'est pas qualifié on prend on sera à
fond d'art mais on prend mais ça sera
par la grande porte quoi oui non mais
oui bah bien sûr comprends pas je suis à
faire d'autre c'est très très heureux
mais surtout que comme je le disais pour
le moment dans les grands prix les deux
joueurs ont gagné autant de matches que
soient les poèmes veulent juste n'est
pas là il a déjà fait une victoire une
finale et une demi donc en soi s'il
passe comme ça ce sera vraiment
m'excuser pour mon profit du règlement
pour une fois ils en profiteraient du
réglage un oui ce serait vraiment bien
voilà c'est bien qu'une époque il peut
lui prendre les places en fait si
soignée pour gagner la finale est né
pouvait qualifier swan et pop est
rennais peut éliminer et signer pour
gagne akira la wild card
elle ira à vicenza et quelque part en
plus ce qui est moche par rapport à ça
c'est que maxime bus et le tournoi ku
pas là il of men qui donne l'élégie
bilino de la wild card à un mec qui est
qui est le seul russe qui peut la voir
et qui lui prendrait enfin j'aurais dit
c'est s'appuie encore plus sur le choix
des tournois où tu vas jointe à de
grandes chez ce tour et des tournois
privés tu fais parce que l'argument
comme quoi ya peu de chances de se
qualifier
heil hoffman bon meilleur sauvable il
est vrai mais en fait il ya peu de
chance pour tout le monde pas un bon
gars où il a eu moins de chance de
gagner le tournoi qui aurait parié sur
lui et alex et une côte puis un
troisième en fait ce must a peu de
chance tu peux aussi d'apprendre quoi
vous ça fait encore plus mal sur le
choix des tournois quoi bref voilà bah
écoutes je sais pas si tu veux garder
l'antenne ou france qui dit non non non
on se quitte merci à tous d'avoir suivi
quand même parce que c'était quand même
une belle journée on la vit vrai quoi
qu'il en soit on irait cru max a tout
donné on y croira encore samedi dimanche
et peut-être lundi néo pop et encore
craqué il a il a déjà montré à plusieurs
reprises qu'il était en
en capacité de faire n'importe quoi j'ai
envie de dire tant le moment le moment
mais c'est le moment et puis nous on va
au caire candidat pouces soyez lui m moi
j'ai envie de dire moi je propose qu'on
envoie le truc à panthère objets simples
mais oui très bons ils ont fini sur une
note positive positif attitude allez les
mecs ont fait leur aide et à et on se
retrouve on se retrouve samedi 14h dieu
nous a offert le twitter banque qu'on
reparlera du tweet ensemble on verra ce
qu'on fait merci à toutes et à tous